the following is a conversation with
Mark Zuckerberg his second time on this
podcast he's the CEO of meta that owns
Facebook Instagram and WhatsApp all
services used by billions of people to
connect with each other we talk about
his vision for the future of meta and
the future of AI in our human world
this is the Lex Friedman podcast and now
dear friends here's Mark Zuckerberg
so you competed in your first suggested
tournament and me as a fellow Jiu Jitsu
practitioner and competitor I think
that's really inspiring given all the
things you have going on so I gotta ask
what was that experience like oh it's
fun I know yeah I mean well look I'm a
pretty competitive person yeah
um doing sports that basically require
your full attention I think is really
important to my like mental health and
and the way I just stay focused at doing
everything I'm doing it's like I decided
to get into martial arts and it's um
it's awesome I got like a ton of my
friends into it we all train together
um we have like a mini Academy in my
garage
um and I guess um in one of my friends
is like hey we should go do a tournament
I was like okay yeah let's do it I'm not
gonna shy away from a challenge like
that so yeah it was but it was it was
awesome it was it was just a lot of fun
you weren't scared there was no fear I
don't know I I was I was pretty sure
that I'd that I'd do okay I like the
confidence um well so for people don't
know Jiu Jitsu is a martial art where
you're trying to break your opponent's
limbs or choke them uh to sleep and do
so with Grace and uh elegance and
efficiency and all that kind of stuff
it's a uh it's a kind of art form I
think that you can do for your whole
life and it's a basically a game a sport
of human chess you can think of there's
a lot of strategy there's a lot of sort
of interesting human dynamics of using
leverage and all that kind of stuff and
uh it's kind of incredible what you
could do you can you could do things
like a small opponent could defeat a
much larger opponent and you get to
understand like the way the mechanics of
the human body works because of that but
you certainly can't be distracted no
yeah it's it's a hundred percent Focus
yeah to to compete I I you know I needed
to get around the fact that I didn't
want it to be like this this big thing
so basically just I rolled up with a hat
and sunglasses and I was wearing a
covered mask and I registered under my
first and middle name so Mark Elliott
and um and it wasn't until I actually
pulled all that stuff off right before I
got on the map that I think people knew
was me so it was it was pretty low-key
but you're still a public figure yeah I
mean I didn't want to lose right the
thing you're partially afraid of is not
just the losing but being almost like
embarrassed it's so raw the sport in
that like it's just you and another
human being there's a primal aspect
there oh yeah it's great for a lot of
people it could be terrifying especially
the first time you're doing the
competing and it wasn't for you I see
the look of excitement in your face yeah
there was no no fear I just think part
of learning is failing okay right so I
mean the main thing like people who who
train Jiu Jitsu it's like you need to
not have pride because I mean all the
stuff you were talking about before
about
you know getting choked or getting you
know a joint lock it's um
you only get into a bad situation if
you're not willing to tap once you
you've already lost right and but
obviously when you're getting started
with something you're not going to be an
expert about it immediately so you just
need to to be willing to go with that
but I think this is like I don't know I
mean maybe I've just been embarrassed
enough times in my life yeah I I do that
there's a thing where like it has people
grow up maybe they don't want to be
embarrassed or anything they've built
their adult identity and they they kind
of have a sense of of who they
they are and what they want to project
and I don't know I think maybe to some
degree
you know your ability to keep doing
interesting things is your willingness
to be embarrassed again and go back to
step one and start as a beginner and get
your ass kicked and you know look stupid
doing things and you know I think so
many of the things that we're doing
whether it's whether it's this I mean
this is just like a kind of a physical
part of my life but
um but running the company it's like we
just take on new adventures and
um
you know all the big things that we're
doing I think of as like 10 plus year
missions that we're on where you know
often early on you know people doubt
that we're gonna be able to do it and
the initial work seems kind of silly and
our whole ethos says we don't want to
wait until something is perfect to put
it out there we want to get it out
quickly and get feedback on it and so I
don't know I mean there's probably just
something about how I approach things in
there but I just kind of think that the
moment that you decide that you're going
to be too embarrassed to try something
new then you're not going to learn
anything anymore but uh like I mentioned
that fear that anxiety could be there
could creep up every once in a while do
do you feel that and especially
stressful moments sort of outside did
you just met just at work
stressful moments big decision days big
decision moments how do you deal with
that fear how do you deal with that
anxiety the thing that stresses me out
the most is always is always the people
challenges you know I kind of think that
um you know strategy questions
you know I tend to have enough
conviction around the values of what
we're trying to do and
what I think matters and what I want our
company to stand for that
those don't really keep me up at night
that much I mean I I kind of you know
it's not that I I get everything right
of course I don't right I mean we make a
lot of mistakes but
um
but I at least have a pretty strong
sense of where I want us to go on that
the the thing in in running a company
for you know almost 20 years now one of
the things that's been pretty clear is
when you have
a team that's cohesive
you can get
almost anything done
and you know you can you can run through
super hard challenges
um you can make hard decisions and push
really hard to to do the best work even
you know and kind of optimize something
super well but when when there's that
tension I mean that's that's when when
things get really tough and you know
when I talk to other friends who run
other companies and things like that I
think one of the things that I actually
spend a disproportionate amount of time
on in running this company is just
fostering a pretty tight core group of
of people who are running the company uh
with me and that to me is is kind of the
thing that
both makes it fun right having having
you know friends and people you've
worked with for a while and new people
and New Perspectives but like a pretty
tight group who can who you can go work
on some of these crazy things with
um but to me that's also the most
stressful thing is when when there are
when there's tension
um you know that's that that weighs on
me I think the you know just it's it's
it's maybe not surprising I mean we're
like a very people focused company and
it's the the people is the the part of
it that that
um you know weighs on me the most to
make sure that we get right but yeah
that that I'd say across everything that
we do is probably
the big thing so when there's tension in
that inner circle of of close folks so
when you trust those folks to help you
make difficult decisions
about uh Facebook WhatsApp Instagram the
future of the company and the metaverse
or the AI
uh how do you build that close-knit
group of folks uh to make those
difficult decisions is there people that
if they have critical voices very
different perspectives on yeah focusing
on the past versus the future all that
kind of stuff yeah I mean I think for
one thing it's just spending a lot of
time with whatever the group is that you
want to be that Core Group
grappling with all of the biggest
challenges and that requires a fair
amount of openness and you know so I
mean a lot of how I I run the company is
you know it's like every Monday morning
we get our it's about the top 30 people
together and we and this is a group that
just worked together for a long period
of time and I mean people people rotate
in I mean new people join people leave
the company people go to other roles in
the company so it's not the the same
group over time but then we spend you
know a lot of times a couple of hours a
lot of the time it's you know can be
somewhat unstructured we like I'll come
with maybe a few topics that I that are
top of mind for me but I'll ask other
people to bring things and people you
know raise questions whether it's okay
there's an issue happening in some
country
um with with some policy issue there's
like a new technology that's developing
here we're having an issue with this
partner
um you know there's a design trade-off
and WhatsApp between two things that
that end up
um being values that we care about
deeply and we need to kind of decide
where we want to be on that and I just
think over time
when um you know by working through a
lot of issues with people and doing it
openly people develop an intuition for
each other and a bond in camaraderie
um and to me developing that is is like
a lot of the fun part of running a
company or doing anything right I think
it's like having having people who are
kind of along on the journey that you're
that you feel like you're doing it with
nothing is ever just one person doing it
other people that disagree also yeah
within that group it's a fairly
combative group okay so combat is part
of it so this is making decisions on
design engineering
uh policy everything everything
everything
yeah I have to ask just back to jiu
jitsu for a little bit what's your
favorite submission now that you've been
doing it what's uh how do you like to
submit your opponent Mark Zuckerberg I'm
in
well first of all I um
do you prefer nogi or Gigi Jiu Jitsu so
ghee is this outfit you wear that uh is
maybe mimics clothing so you can choke
what's like a kimono it's like the
traditional martial arts
um
that you could choke people with yes
well it's got the lapels yes yeah
um so I like Jiu Jitsu I also really
like MMA and so I think nogi more
closely approximates MMA and I think my
style is
um is maybe a little closer to an MMA
style so like a lot of Jiu Jitsu players
are fine being on their back right and
obviously having a good guard is is a
critical part of of Jiu Jitsu but but in
MMA you don't want to be on your back
right because even if you have control
you're just taking punches while you're
on your back so
um so that's no good do you like being
on top my style is I'm probably more
pressure and
um and yeah and and I'd probably rather
be the top player but
um but I'm also smaller right I'm not
I'm not like a a heavyweight guy right
so from that perspective I think like
you know it's especially because you
know from doing a competition I'll
compete with people who are my size but
a lot of my friends are bigger than me
so
um so back takes probably pretty
important right because that's where you
have the most leverage Advantage right
where where
um you know people you know their arms
your arms are very weak behind you right
so
um so being able to get to the back and
and take that pretty important but I
don't know I feel like the right
strategy is to not be too committed to
any single submission but that said I
don't like hurting people so
um so I always think that chokes are are
a somewhat more human way to go than
than joint locks yeah and it's more
about control it's less Dynamic so
you're basically like a Habib numbering
a Madoff type of fighter so so let's go
yeah a back take to a rear naked choke I
think it's like the clean the clean way
to go straightforward answer right there
what advice would you give to um to
people looking to start learning Jiu
Jitsu given how busy you are given where
you are in life that you're able to do
this you're able to train you're able to
compete and get uh to learn something
from this interesting art
why'd you think you have to be willing
to um
to just get beaten up a lot yeah I mean
but I mean over time I think that
there's there's a flow to all these
things and there's um you know
one of the
one of I don't know my experiences that
I think kind of transcends you know
running a company in the different
different activities that I like doing
or I I really believe that like if
you're going to accomplish whatever
anything a lot of it is just being
willing to push through right and having
the grit and determination to to to push
through difficult situations
um I think for a lot of people that
um that ends up being sort of a
Difference Maker between the people you
know who who kind of get the most done
and not I mean there's all these
questions about like
um you know how how many days people
want to work and things like that I
think almost all the people who like
start successful companies or things
like that are just are working extremely
hard but I think one of the things that
you learn both by you know doing this
over time or you know very acutely with
things like Jiu Jitsu or surfing is um
you can't push through everything
and
I think that that's
you you learn this stuff very acutely
you run doing sports compared to running
a company because running a company the
cycle times are so long right it's like
you start a project and then you know
it's like months later or you know if
you're building Hardware it could be
years later before you're actually
getting feedback and able to you know
make the next set of decisions for the
next version of the thing that you're
doing whereas you one of the things that
I just think is mentally so nice about
these very high turnaround
conditioning Sports things like that is
you get feedback very quickly right it's
like okay like I don't counter something
correctly you get punched in the face
right so not in Jiu Jitsu you know you
don't get punched in Jiu Jitsu but an
MMA
um there are all these analogies between
all these things that I think actually
hold that are that are like
important life lessons right it's like
okay you're surfing a wave it's like
you know sometimes you're like you can't
go in the other direction on it right
it's like there are limits to kind of
what you know it's like a foil you can
you can pump the foil and and push
pretty hard in a bunch of directions but
like yeah you you know it's at some
level like the momentum against you is
is strong enough you're that's not gonna
work and and I do think that
um that's sort of a a humbling but also
an important lesson for I think people
who are running things or building
things it's like yeah you you um you
know a lot of the game is just being
able to kind of push and and and and
work through complicated things but you
also need to kind of have enough of an
understanding like which things you just
can't push through and where where um
um the Finesse is more important yeah
what are your Jiu Jitsu life lessons
well I think you did it
you made it sound so simple
and we're so eloquent that it's easy to
miss
but basically being okay and accepting
the wisdom and the joy in the uh getting
your ass kicked
in the full range of what that means I
think that's a big gift of the being
humbled
somehow being humbled especially
physically opens your mind to the the
full process of learning what it means
to learn which is being willing to suck
at something I think Jiu-Jitsu is just
very repetitively efficiently humbles
you over and over and over and over to
where you can carry that lessons to
places where you don't get humbled as
much whether it's research or running a
company or building stuff the the cycle
is longer and you just so you can just
get humbled in a period of an hour over
and over and over and over especially
when you're a beginner you'll have a
little person
just you know somebody much smarter than
you just kick your ass uh repeatedly uh
definitively where there's no argument
oh yeah and then you you literally tap
because if you don't tap you're going to
die so this is an agreement
you could have killed me just now but
we're friends so you were going to agree
that you're not going to and that kind
of humbling process it just does
something to your psyche to Your Ego
that puts it in its proper context to
realize that you know everything
in this life is like a journey from
sucking through a hard process of
improving or
rigorously day after day after day after
day like any kind of success requires
hard work
um yeah it's just some more than a lot
of sports I would say because I've done
a lot of them it really teaches you that
and you made it sound so simple like I'm
almost you know it's it's okay it's part
of the process you just get humble get
yourself I've just failed and been
embarrassed so many times in my life
that like you know I'm I'm it's a core
competence of this it's a core
competence well yes and there's a deep
truth to that being able to and you said
it in the very beginning which is that's
the thing that stops US especially as
you get older especially as you develop
expertise in certain areas the
not being willing to be a beginner in a
new area yeah uh that because that's
where the growth happens is being
willing to be a beginner being willing
to be embarrassed saying something
stupid doing something stupid
um a lot of us to get good at one thing
we want to show that off and it sucks
uh being a beginner but it's it's where
growth happens
yeah well speaking of which let me ask
you about AI it seems like this year for
the entirety of the human civilization
is an interesting year for the
development of artificial intelligence
a lot of interesting stuff is happening
So Meta is a big part of that
met has developed llama which is a 65
billion parameter model
uh there's a lot of interesting
questions I can ask here one of which
has to do with open source but first can
you tell the story of developing of this
model and uh making the complicated
decision of how to release it yeah sure
I think you're right first of all that
in the last year there have been a bunch
of advances on scaling up these large
Transformer models so there's the
language equivalent of it with large
language models uh the sort of the image
generation equivalent with these large
diffusion models
um there's a lot of fundamental research
that's gone into this and
meta has taken the approach
of being quite open and academic in in
our development
um of AI part of this is we want to have
the best people in the world researching
this and
um and a lot of the best people want to
know that they're going to be able to
share their work so that's part of the
deal that we that we have is that you
know we can get you know if you're one
of the top AI researchers in the world
you can come here you can get access to
kind of industry scale
infrastructure and and and part of our
ethos is that we we want to share what's
what's invented
um broadly we do that with a lot of the
the different AI tools that we create
and llama is the language model that
that our research team made and
you know we we did in a limited
um a limited open source release for it
right where which was intended for
researchers to be able to use it
um
but you know responsibility and getting
safety right on these is um is very
important so we didn't think that
for the first one there were a bunch of
questions around whether we should be
releasing this commercially so we kind
of punched it on that for for V1 of of
llama and and just released it from
research now obviously by releasing it
for research
um you know it's out there but but
companies know that that they're that
they're not supposed to kind of put it
into commercial releases and um you know
we're working on the follow-up models
for this and and thinking through how
how um what what the the how exactly
this should work for for follow-on now
that we've had time to to work on a lot
more of the the safety and
um and the pieces around that but but
overall I mean this is
I just kind of think that
that it would be good
if there were a lot of different folks
who had the ability to build state of
the art technology here
you know it's and not just a small
number of of big companies we're to
train one of these AI models the
state-of-the-art models is um it just
takes you know hundreds of millions of
dollars of infrastructure right so there
are not that many organizations in the
world
um that can do that at the biggest scale
today and no it gets it gets more
efficient every day so
um so I I do think that that will be
available to more folks over time but
but I just think like there's there's
all this Innovation out there that
people can create and um
and and I I just think that will will
also learn a lot by by seeing what the
whole community of students and
um and hackers and startups and
different folks
um build with this and that's kind of
that's kind of been how we've approached
this and it's also we've done a lot of
our infrastructure and we took our whole
data center design and our server design
and we we built this open compute
project where we just made that public
and
um part of the theory was like all right
if we make it's that more people can use
this server design then um then that'll
enable more Innovation it'll also make
the server design more efficient and
that'll that'll make our business more
efficient too so that's worked and we've
we've just done this with a lot of our
our infrastructure
so for people who don't know you did the
limited release I think in February of
one of this year of llama
and it got quote unquote leaked
meaning like it's uh
escaped
the uh the the limited release aspect
but it was
you know that something you probably
anticipated given that it's just
released we shared it with researchers
right so it's just trying to make sure
that there's like a slow release yeah uh
but from there I just would love to get
your comment on what happened next which
is like this is a very vibrant open
source community that just builds stuff
on top of it there's uh llama CPP
basically stuff that makes it more
efficient to run on smaller computers uh
there's combining with uh reinforcement
learning with human feedback so some of
the different interesting fine-tuning
mechanisms there's then also like
fine-tuning and a GPT three generations
there's a lot of uh GPT for all alpaca
uh colossal AI all these kinds of models
just kind of spring up like
run on top of wood yeah like what do you
think about that no I think it's been
really neat to see I mean there's been
folks who are getting it to run on local
devices right so if you're an individual
who just you know wants to experiment
you know with this at home
you probably don't have a large budget
to get access to like a large amount of
cloud compute so getting it to run on
your local laptop
um you know is is uh is pretty good
right and pretty relevant
um and then there are things like yeah
llama CPP
um re-implemented it more efficiently so
you know now even when we run our own
versions of it we can do it on way less
compute and it just way more efficient
save a lot of money
um for everyone who uses this so that
that is is is good
um
I do think it's worth calling out that
because this was a relatively early
release
um
llama isn't quite as on the frontier as
for example the biggest open AI models
or the biggest Google models right when
you mentioned that the largest llama
model that we released had 65 billion
parameters and when no one knows you
know I guess outside of open AI exactly
what the specs are for um for for gpd4
but but I I think the you know my
understanding is it's like 10 times
bigger and I think Google's Palm model
is is also I think has about 10 times as
many parameters now the Llama models are
very efficient so they perform well for
for something that's around 65 billion
parameters so for me that was also part
of this because there's this whole
debate around you know is it good for
everyone in the world to have access to
um to the most Frontier AI models and I
I think as the AI models start
approaching something that's like a
super human intelligent sense like that
that's a bigger question that we'll have
to Grapple with but right now I mean
these are still you know very basic
tools they're um you know they're
they're powerful in the sense that you
know a lot of Open Source software like
databases or web servers can enable a
lot of pretty important things
um but
I don't think anyone looks at the the
you know the current generation of llama
and thinks it's um you know anywhere
near a super intelligence so I think
that a bunch of those questions around
like is it is it good to to kind of get
out there I think at this stage surely
you you want more researchers working on
it for all the reasons that
um that open source software has a lot
of advantages and we talked about
efficiency before but another one is
just open source software tends to be
more secure because you have more people
looking at it openly and scrutinizing it
and finding holes in it
um and that makes it more safe so I
think at this point it's more
I think it's generally agreed upon that
open source software is generally more
secure and safer
um than things that are kind of
developed in a silo where people try to
get through security through obscurity
so I think that for the scale of of what
we're seeing now with AI
I think we're more likely to get to you
know good alignment and good
um understanding of of kind of what
needs to do to make this work well by
having it be open source and and that's
something that I think is is quite good
to have out there and and happening
publicly at this point meta released a
lot of models as open source so uh the
Massillon multi-lingual speech model
I'll ask you questions about those but
the point is
uh you've open source quite a lot you've
been spearheading the open source
movement where's uh that's really
positive inspiring to see from one angle
from the research angle of course
there's folks who are really terrified
about the existential threat of
artificial intelligence and those folks
will say that you know
um you have to be careful about the open
sourcing uh step but where do you see
the future of Open Source here uh as
part of meta the tension here is do you
want to release the magic sauce that's
one
tension and the other one is uh do you
want to put a powerful tool in the hands
of uh Bad actors even though it probably
has a huge amount of positive impact
also
yeah I mean again
stage that we're at in the development
of AI I don't think anyone looks at the
current state of things and thinks that
this is super intelligence
um and you know the models that we're
talking about for the Llama models here
are you know generally an order of
magnitude smaller than what open AI or
Google are doing so
I think that at least for the stage that
we're at now the equities
balance strongly in my view towards
doing this more openly
um I think if you got something that was
closer to Super intelligence then I
think you'd have to discuss that more
and and think through that
um a lot more and we haven't made a
decision yet as to what we would do if
we were in that position but I don't
think I think there's a good chance that
we're pretty far off from that position
so
um so
I'm not
uh I'm certainly not saying that the
position that we're taking on this now
applies to every single thing that we
would ever do and you know certainly
inside the company and we probably do
more open source work than
you know most of the other big tech
companies but we also don't open source
everything and a lot of our the core
kind of app code for WhatsApp or
Instagram or something I mean we're not
open sourcing that it's not like a a
general enough piece of software that
would be useful for a lot of people to
do different things
um you know whereas
the software that we do whether it's
like a an open source server design or
um or basically you know things like
memcache right like a good you know it
was probably our earliest project
um that I worked on it was probably one
of the last things that I that I coded
and and led directly for the company
um but but basically this like caching
tool
um for for quick data retrieval
um these are things that are just
broadly useful across like anything that
you want to build and and I think that
some of the
language models now have that feel as
well as some of the other things that
we're building like the translation tool
that that you just referenced so text to
speech and speech to text you've
expanded it from around 100 languages to
more than 1100 languages yeah and you
can identify more than the model can
identify more than
4 000 spoken languages which is 40 times
more than any known previous technology
to me that's really really exciting in
terms of connecting the world breaking
down barriers that language creates yeah
I think being able to translate between
all of these different
pieces in real time this has been a
kind of common sci-fi idea that we'd all
have you know whether it's
on an earbud or glasses or something
that can help translate in real time
um between all these different languages
and that's one that I think technology
is basically delivering now so I think
yeah I think that's pretty pretty
exciting uh you mentioned the next
version of llama what can you say about
the next version of llama
what what can you say about like what uh
what were you working on in terms of
release in terms of the vision for that
well a lot of what we're doing is taking
the first version which was primarily
you know this research version and
trying to now build a version that has
all of the latest state-of-the-art
safety precautions built in
um and and we're
um we're using some more data to train
it from across our services but
but a lot of the the work that we're
doing internally is really just focused
on making sure that this is
um you know as
aligned and responsible as possible and
you know we're building a lot of our own
you know we're talking about kind of the
open source infrastructure but you know
the
the main thing that we focus on building
here are you know a lot of product
experiences to help people connect and
express themselves so yeah we're gonna
I've talked about a bunch of this stuff
but um you'll have an assistant that you
can talk to in WhatsApp
um you know I think I I think in the
future every Creator will will have kind
of an AI agent that can kind of act on
their behalf that their fans can talk to
I I want to get to the point where every
small business basically has an AI agent
that people can talk to for you know to
do Commerce and customer support and
things like that so they're going to be
all these different things and
llama or the language model underlying
this is is basically going to be the
engine that powers that the reason to
open source it is that um as we did with
um with the the first version is that it
uh
basically it unlocks a lot of innovation
in the ecosystem will make our products
better as well and also gives us a lot
of valuable feedback on security and
safety which is important for making
this good but yeah I mean the the work
that we're doing to advance the
infrastructure it's um it's basically at
this point taking it Beyond a research
project into something which is ready to
be kind of core infrastructure not only
for our own products but
um you know hopefully for for a lot of
other things out there too do you think
the Llama Or the language model
underlying that version two will be open
sourced
you're you have internal debate around
that the pros and cons and so on this is
I mean we were talking about the debates
that we have internally and I think
um
I think the question is how to do it
right I mean it's I think we
you know we did the research license for
V1 and and I think the the big thing
that we're that we're thinking about is
is basically like what's the what's the
right the right way so there was a leak
that happened I don't know if you can
comment on it for V1 you know we
released it as a research project
um for researchers to be able to use but
in doing so we put it out there so
um you know we were very clear that
anyone who uses the the code and the
weights doesn't have a commercial
license to put into products and we've
we've generally seen people respect that
right it's like you don't have any
reputable companies that are basically
trying to put this into into
um their commercial products but but
yeah but by sharing it with you know so
many researchers it's it's you know yeah
it did leave the building but uh what
have you learned from that process that
you might be able to apply to V2 about
how to release it safely effectively uh
if if you release it yeah well I mean I
think a lot of the feedback like I said
is just around you know different things
around you know how do you fine-tune
models to make them more aligned and
safer and you see all the different data
recipes that
um you know you mentioned a lot of
different
projects that are based on this I mean
there's one at Berkeley there's you know
it's just like all over and um
and
people have tried a lot of different
things and we've tried a bunch of stuff
internally so kind of where we're we're
making progress here but also we're able
to learn from some of the best ideas in
the community and you know I think it
you know we want to just continue
continue pushing that forward but I
don't have any news to announce um if
that's if that's what you're you're
asking I mean this is a a thing that
we're uh
we're still we're still kind of you know
actively working through the the right
way to move forward here the details of
the secret sauce are still being
developed I see uh can you comment on
what do you think of uh the thing that
worked for gbt which is the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback so doing this alignment process
do you find it interesting and as part
of that let me ask because I talked to
Jan lacun before talking to you today he
asked me to ask or suggested that I ask
do you think
llm fine tuning will need to be
crowdsourced Wikipedia Style
so crowdsourcing so this kind of idea of
how to integrate the human in the fine
tuning of these Foundation models yeah I
think that's a really interesting idea
that I've talked to Jan about a bunch
um
and
we were talking about
how do you basically train these models
to be as as safe and aligned and
responsible as possible and you know
different groups out there who are doing
development test different data recipes
in fine tuning but this idea that you
you just mentioned is
that at the end of the day
instead of having kind of one group
fine-tune some stuff and another group
you know produce a different fine-tuning
recipe and then
I was trying to figure out which one we
think works best to produce the most
aligned model
um
I I do think that
it would be nice if you could get to a
point where you had a Wikipedia style
collaborative
way for a kind of a broader Community to
um to fine tune it as well now there's a
lot of challenges in that both from an
infrastructure and like uh Community
Management and product perspective about
how you do that so I I haven't worked
that out yet
um but as an idea I think it's it's
quite compelling and I think it it goes
well with the ethos of open sourcing the
technology is also finding a way to have
a kind of Community Driven
um
a Community Driven training of it
um but I think there are a lot of
questions on this in general these this
these questions around what's the the
best way to produce aligned AI models
it's very much a research area and it's
one that I think we will need to make as
much progress on as the kind of core
intelligence capability of the of the um
the models themselves well I just did a
conversation with Jimmy Wales the
founder of Wikipedia and to me Wikipedia
is one of the greatest websites ever
created
and it's a kind of a miracle that it
works and I think it has to do with
something that you mentioned which is
community you have a small community of
editors
that somehow work together well and they
uh they handle very controversial
topics and they handle it
with balance and with Grace despite sort
of the attacks that will often happen a
lot of the time I mean it's not it's it
has issues just like any other human
system but yes I mean the balance is I
mean it's a it's amazing what they've
been able to achieve but it's also not
perfect and I think that that's
um there's still a lot of challenges
right it's uh the more controversial the
topic the more the more difficult uh the
uh
the journey towards quote-unquote truth
or knowledge or wisdom that Wikipedia
tries to capture in the same way AI
models will need to
be able to generate those same things
truth knowledge and wisdom and how do
you align those models that they
generate
um something that uh is closest to truth
there's these concerns about
misinformation all this kind of stuff
that nobody can Define
and it's a it's something that we
together as a human species have to
Define like what is truth and how to
help AI systems generate that is one of
the things language models do really
well is generate convincing sounding
things they can be completely wrong
and so how do you align it
uh to be less wrong
and part of that is the training and
part of that is the alignment and
however you do the alignment stage and
just like you said it's a very new and a
very open research problem
yeah and I think there's also
a lot of questions about whether the
current architecture for llms
as you continue scaling it what happens
um I mean a lot of the a lot of what's
been exciting in the last year
is that there's there's clearly a
qualitative breakthrough where you know
with with some of the GPT models
um that opened I put out and and that
others have been able to do as well I I
think it reached a kind of level of
quality where people like wow this is
this feels different and
um
and like it's going to be able to be the
foundation for building a lot of awesome
products and experiences and value but I
think the other realization that people
have is wow we just made a breakthrough
um
if there are other breakthroughs quickly
then I think that there's the sense that
maybe where we're closer to general
intelligence but I think that that idea
is predicated on the idea that I I think
people believe that there's still
generally a bunch of additional
breakthroughs to make and that it's um
we just don't know
how long it's going to take to get there
and you know one view that some people
have
um this doesn't tend to be my view as
much is that simply
scaling the current llms and you know
getting to higher parameter count models
by itself we'll we'll get to something
that is closer to um to to general
intelligence but
um I don't know I tend to think that
there's probably more more um
if fundamental steps that need to be
taken along the way there but still the
leaves taken
with this extra alignment step is quite
incredible quite surprising to to a lot
of folks and on top of that
when you start to have hundreds of
millions of people potentially using a
product that integrates that
you can start to see civilization
transforming effects before you achieve
super quote-unquote super intelligence
it could be super transformative without
being a super intelligence oh yeah I
mean I think that they're going to be a
lot of amazing products and value that
can be created with the current level of
Technology
um
to some degree
you know I'm excited to
work on a lot of those products over the
next few years and I think it would just
create
a tremendous amount of whiplash if the
number of breakthroughs keeps like if if
they keep on being stacked breakthroughs
because I think to some degree industry
in the world needs some time to kind of
build these breakthroughs into the
products and experiences that we all use
so we can actually benefit from them
um
but
I don't know I think there's just a a
like an awesome amount of stuff to do I
mean I think about like all of the
I don't know small businesses or
individual entrepreneurs out there who
um you know now we're going to be able
to you know get help coding the things
that they need to go build things or
designing the things that they need or
um we'll be able to you know use these
models to be able to do customer support
for the people that they're that they're
serving you know over WhatsApp without
having to you know I I think that that's
that's just gonna be I just think that
this is all going to be yeah super
exciting it's going to create better
better experiences for people and just
unlock a ton of innovation and value
so I don't know if you know but uh
you know what is it over three billion
people use WhatsApp Facebook and
Instagram
uh so any kind of AI fueled products
that go into that like we're talking
about anything with llms will have a
tremendous amount of impact do you have
ideas and thoughts about
possible products
that might start being integrated into
uh into these platforms used by so many
people yeah I think there's three main
categories of things that we're working
on
um
the first that I think is probably the
most interesting
is um
you know there's this notion of like
you're gonna have an assistant or or an
agent who you can talk to and I think
probably the biggest thing that's
different about my view of how this
plays out from what I see with um with
openai and Google and others is you know
everyone else is building like
the One Singular AI right it's like okay
you talk to chat GPT or you talk to Bard
or you talk to Bing and
my view is that
that they're going to be a lot of
different AIS that people are going to
want to engage with just like you want
to use
um you know a number of different apps
for different things and you have
relationships with different people in
your life who feel different emotional
roles for you
um and I am
so I think that they're going to be
people have a reason that they that I
think you don't just want like a
singular Ai and that that I think is
probably the biggest distinction in in
terms of how I think about this and a
bunch of these things I think you'll
you'll want an assistant
um I mean I mentioned a couple of these
before I think like every Creator who
you interact with will ultimately want
some kind of AI that can proxy them and
be something that their fans can
interact with or that allows them to
interact with their fans
um this is like the common Creator
promise everyone's trying to build a
community and engage with people and
they want tools to be able to amplify
themselves more and be able to do that
um but
but you only have 24 hours in a day so
um so I think having the ability to
basically like bottle up your
personality and
um or you know like give your fans
information about when you're performing
a concert or something like that I mean
that's that I think is going to be
something that's super valuable but it's
not just that you know again it's not
this idea that I think people are going
to want Just One Singular AI I think
you're gonna You Know You're Gonna Want
to interact with a lot of different
entities and then I think there's the
business version of this too which we've
touched on a couple of times which is
um
I think every business in the world is
going to want
basically an AI that that you know it's
like you have your page on Instagram or
Facebook or Whatsapp or whatever and you
wanna you wanna Point people to
an AI that people can interact with but
you want to know that that AI is only
going to sell your products you don't
want it you know recommending your
competitors stuff right so so it's not
like there can be like just uh you know
One Singular AI that that can answer all
the questions for a person because you
know that ques like that I might not
actually be aligned with you as a
business to
um to really just do the best job
providing support for for your product
so I think that there's going to be a
clear need
um in the market and in people's lives
for there to be a bunch of these part of
that is figuring out the research the
technology that enables the
personalization that you're talking
about so not one centralized god-like
llm but one just a huge diversity of
them that's fine-tuned to particular
needs particular Styles particular
businesses particular Brands all that
kind of stuff and also enabling just
enabling people to create them really
easily for the you know for to for your
own business or if you're a Creator to
be able to help you engage with your
fans and I think that's
um so yeah I think that there there's a
clear kind of interesting product
Direction here that I think is fairly
unique from from what in any of the
other big companies there are taking
um it also aligns well with this sort of
Open Source approach because again we we
sort of believe in this more
community-oriented uh more democratic
approach to building out the products
and Technology around this we don't
think that there's going to be the one
true thing we think that there there
should be kind of a lot of development
so
that part of things I think is going to
be really interesting and we could we
could go probably spent a lot of time
talking about that and the the kind of
implications of um of that approach
being different from what others are
taking
um but there's a bunch of other simpler
things that I think we're also going to
do just going back to your question
around
how this finds its way into like what do
we build
um they're going to be a lot of simpler
things around
um
okay you you post photos on Instagram
and Facebook and you know in WhatsApp
and messenger and like you want the
photos to look as good as possible so
like having an AI that you can just like
take a photo and then just tell it like
okay I want to edit this thing or
describe this it's like I think we're
gonna have tools that are just way
better than than what we've historically
had on this
um and that's more in the image and
media generation side than the large
language model side but but it's it all
kind of you know plays off of advances
in the same space
um is there a lot of tools that I think
are just going to get built into every
one of our products I think every single
thing that we do is gonna basically get
evolved in this direction right it's
like in the future if you're advertising
on our services like do you need to make
your own kind of AD creative it's no
you'll just you know you just tell us
okay I'm I'm a dog walker and I
and I'm willing to walk people's dogs
and
help me find the right people and like
create the ad unit that will perform the
best and like give an objective to to
the system and it just kind of
like connects you with the right people
well that's a super powerful idea
of generating the language almost like a
rigorous a b testing for you
that works to find the the best customer
for your thing I mean to me
advertisement when done well
just finds a good match between a human
being and a thing that will make that
human being happy
yeah totally and do that if as
efficiently as possible when it's done
well people actually like it you know
it's um yeah I think there's a lot of
examples where it's not done well and
it's annoying and I think that's what
kind of gives it a bad rap but
um but yeah and a lot of the stuff is
possible today I mean obviously a b
testing stuff is built into a lot of
these Frameworks the thing that's new is
having technology that can generate the
ideas for about what to a B test
something that that's exciting so this
will just be across like
everything that we're doing right all
the metaverse stuff that we're doing
right it's like you want to create
worlds in the future you'll just
describe them and then it'll create the
code for you so the natural language
becomes the the interface we use for
all the ways we interact with the
computer with
with the digital or them yeah yeah
totally yeah which is what everyone can
do using natural language and with
translation you can do it any kind of
language
um I I mean for the personalization is
really really really interesting
yeah it unlocks so many possible things
I mean I for one look forward to
creating a copy of myself
I know we talked about this last time
but this has since the last time this
becomes now we're closer
much closer like I could literally just
haven't interacted with some of these
language models I could see the Absurd
situation where I'll have a uh large uh
or a Lex language model and I'll have to
have a conversation with him about like
Hey listen
like you're just getting out of line and
having a conversation where you
fine-tune that thing to be a little bit
more respectful or something like this I
mean that's that's going to be the
that seems like an amazing product
for businesses for humans just not not
just the assistant that's facing the
individual but the assistant that
represents the individual to the public
both both directions
there's basically a layer that is the AI
system through which you interact with
the outside world with the outside world
that has humans in it that's really
interesting and you that have social
networks that connect billions of people
it seems like a
heck of a large scale place to test some
of this stuff out
yeah I mean I think part of the reason
why creators will want to do this is
because they already have the
communities on our services
yeah and and a lot of the interface for
this stuff today
are chat type interfaces and and between
WhatsApp and and messenger I think that
those are you know just great great ways
to to interact with people so some of
this is philosophy but do you see do you
see any term future where you have some
of the people you're friends with
our AI systems on these social networks
on Facebook on Instagram even even on
WhatsApp having having conversations
where some heterogeneous some human some
is AI I think we'll get to that
um you know and you know if only just
empirically looking at
then Microsoft released this thing
called show ice several years ago in in
China it was a pre-llm chatbot
technology that it was a lot simpler
than what's possible today
and I think there's like tens of
millions of people were using this and
and just you know really it became quite
attached and you know built
relationships with it and I think that
there's
um you know there's services today like
replica where you know people are doing
things like that and
um so I I think that there's there's
certainly
you know needs for companionship that
people have you know older people
um
uh and it's I I think most people I
don't have as many friends as they would
like to have right if you look at
um there's some interesting demographic
studies around
like
the average person has
the number of close friends that they
have is
um fewer today than it was 15 years ago
and I mean
that gets to like this is like the core
thing that
that I think about in terms of you know
Building Services that help connect
people so I think you'll get tools that
help people connect with each other are
going to be you know the primary thing
that we want to do
um so you can imagine you know AI
assistance that you know just do a
better job of reminding you when it's
your friend's birthday and how you could
celebrate them right it's like right now
we have like the little box in the
corner of the website that tells you
whose birthday it is and stuff like that
but it's
um but you know at some level you don't
just want to like send everyone a note
that's the same note saying happy
birthday with an emoji right so having
something that's more of an you know a a
social assistant in that sense and like
that can you know update you on what's
going on in their life and like how how
you can reach out to them effectively
um help you be a better friend I think
that that's something that's super
powerful too
um but
yeah beyond that
um and there are all these different
flavors of
kind of personal AIS that I think could
exist so I think an assistant is sort of
the the kind of simplest one to wrap
your head around but
um
like a mentor or a life coach
um if someone who can give you advice
um who's maybe like a bit of a
cheerleader who can help pick you up
through all the challenges that that um
you know inevitably you know we all go
through on a daily basis and that
there's probably you know some some role
for something like that and then you
know all the way you can you might just
go through a lot of the the different
type of kind of functional
relationships that people have in their
life and you know I would I would bet
that there will be companies out there
that take a crack at at um at a lot of
these things so
um I don't know I think it's part of the
interesting Innovation that's going to
exist is is that there there's certainly
a lot
um like education tutors right it's like
I just look at you know my kids
learning to code and you know they love
it
um but you know it's like they get stuck
on a question and they have to wait till
like
I can help answer it right or someone
else who they know can help answer the
question in the future they'll just
there will be like a coding assistant
that they have that is like designed to
you know be perfect for teaching a five
and a seven year old how to code and and
they'll just be able to ask questions
all the time and you know be extremely
patient it's never going to get annoyed
at them right
um I think that like there are all these
different kind of relationships or
functional relationships that we have in
our lives that
um they're really interesting and I
think one of the big questions is like
okay is this all gonna just get bucketed
into
you know One Singular AI I just I just
don't I don't think so do you think
about this actually a question from
Reddit uh what the long-term effects of
human communication when people can talk
with in quotes talk with others through
a chat bot that augments their language
automatically rather than developing
social skills by making mistakes and
learning uh will people just communicate
by grunts in a generation and do you
think about long-term effects at scale
the integration of AI in our social
interaction
yeah I mean I think it's mostly
good I I mean that that was that
question was sort of framed in a
negative way but I mean we were talking
before about
language models helping you communicate
with uh it was like language translation
helping you communicate with people who
don't speak your language I mean at some
level
would all the social technology is doing
is helping people
um
Express themselves
better to people
in in situations where they would
otherwise have a hard time doing that so
part of it might be okay because you
speak a language that I don't know
that's a pretty basic one that you know
I don't think people are going to look
at that and say it's sad that do we have
the capacity to do that because I should
have just learned your language right I
mean that's that's pretty high bar but
um
but overall I'd say um
they're all these impediments
and language is an imperfect way
for people to express thoughts and ideas
it's you know one of the best that we
have we have that we have art we have
code
but language is also a mapping of the
way you think the way you see the world
the way who you are and one of the
applications I've recently talked to a
person who who's uh actually a jiu jitsu
instructor
um he said that when he uh emails
parents about
their son and daughter
um that they can improve their
discipline in class and so on he often
finds that he comes off a bit of more of
an [__] than he would like so he uses
GPT to translate his original email into
a nicer email
we hear this all the time a lot of
creators on our services tell us that
one of the most stressful things
um is basically negotiating deals with
Brands and stuff like the business side
of it because they're like I mean they
do their thing right and and you know
the creators they're they're excellent
at what they do and they just want to
connect with their Community but then
they get really stressed you know they
go into their their DMS and they see
some brand wants to do some with them
and they
don't quite know how to negotiate or how
to push back respectfully and
um so I think building a tool that can
actually allow them to do that well is
you know one simple thing that that I
think is just like an interesting thing
that that we've heard from a bunch of
people that that they'd be interested in
but I'm going back to the broader idea
um
I I don't know I mean you know I just
Priscilla and I just had our third
daughter
um congratulations thank you
and and you know it's like one of the
saddest things in the world is like
seeing your baby cry right but like it's
like what why is that right it's like
well because babies don't generally have
much capacity to tell you what they
care about otherwise right it's not
actually just babies right it's um you
know my five-year-old daughter cries too
because she sometimes has a hard time
expressing you know what what um matters
to to her and and I was thinking about
that and it's like well you know
actually a lot of adults get very
frustrated too because they can't they
have a hard time expressing things in a
way that going back to some of the early
themes that
maybe is something that you know is a
mistake or maybe they have pride or
something like all these things get in
the way so I don't know I think that all
these different technologies that can
help us navigate the social complexity
and actually be able to better express
our what we're feeling and thinking I
think that's generally all good and um
there are always these concerns like
okay are people gonna have worse
memories because you have Google to look
things up and and I think in general a
generation later you don't look back and
lament that I think it's you're just
like wow we have so much more capacity
to to do so much more now and I think
that that'll be the case here too you
can allocate those cognitive
capabilities to like deeper like nuanced
thought yeah
uh yeah but it's change so with with uh
just like with Google search
the the additional language models large
language models
you basically don't have to remember
nearly as much
just like with stack Overflow for
programming now that these language
models can generate code right there I
mean I find that I write like maybe
eighty percent ninety percent of the
code I write is as uh not generated
first and then edited I mean so you
don't have to remember how to write
specifics of different functions oh
that's great and it's also it's not just
the the specific
coding I mean in the in the context of
uh
of a large company like this I think
before an engineer can sit down to code
they first need to
figure out all of the library's
independencies that you know tens of
thousands of people have written before
them and
um you know one of the things that I'm
excited about they're working on is it's
not just um you know tools that help
Engineers code it's tools that can help
summarize the whole knowledge base and
and help people be able to navigate all
the internal information and I think
that's
um in the experiments that I've done
with this stuff I mean that's
on the public stuff you just you know
ask ask
um
one of these models to
build you a script that does anything
and it basically already understands
what the best libraries are to do that
thing and pulls them in automatically
it's I mean I think that's super
powerful that was always I the most
annoying part of coding was that you had
to spend all this time actually figuring
out what the resources were that you
were supposed to import before you could
actually start building the thing yeah I
mean there's of course
the flip side of that I think for the
most part is positive but the flip side
is if you Outsource that thinking to an
AI model you might miss nuanced mistakes
and bugs they're good you lose the skill
to find those bugs
and those bugs might be uh the code
looks very convincingly right
but it's actually wrong in a very subtle
way
but that's that's the trade-off that we
uh
that we face as human civilization when
we build more and more powerful tools
when we stand on the shoulders of taller
and taller Giants we could do more but
then we forget how to do all the stuff
that they did
foreign
it's a weird trade-off yeah I agree I
mean I think it's I think it is very
valuable in your life to be able to do
basic things too
do you worry about some of the
concerns of bots being present on social
networks more and more human-like Bots
that are
not necessarily trying to do a good
thing or they might be explicitly trying
to do a bad thing like phishing scams
yeah like social engineering all that
kind of stuff which has always been a
very difficult problem for social
networks but now it's becoming almost a
more and more difficult problem well I
think there's a few different parts of
of this so one is
there are all these harms that we need
to basically fight against and prevent
and and that's been you know a lot of
our Focus over the last
you know five or seven years is
basically ramping up very sophisticated
AI systems not generative AI systems
more kind of classical AI systems to be
able to
um you know categorize and classify and
identify
okay this this post looks like it's um
promoting terrorism this one is you know
like exploiting children this one is
um looks like it might be trying to
incite violence this one's an
intellectual uh property violation so
there's there's like that's like 18
different categories of of violating
kind of harmful content that we've had
to build specific systems to be able to
track and
um
I think it's certainly the case that
advances in generative AI
will test those
um
but at least so far it's been the case
and and I'm optimistic that it will
continue to be the case that we will be
able to bring more computing power to
Bear to have even stronger AIS that can
help defend against those things so
um we've had to deal with some
adversarial issues before right it's I
mean for for some things like hate
speech it's like people aren't generally
getting a lot more sophisticated like
the average person who let's say you
know if someone's saying some kind of
racist thing right it's like they're not
necessarily getting more sophisticated
at being racist right it just it's okay
so that the system can just find but
then there's other adversaries who
actually are very sophisticated like
nation states doing things and you know
we find
you know whether it's Russia or you know
just different countries that are
basically standing up these networks of
um of bots or or
um inauthentic accounts is what is what
we call them because they're not
necessarily Bots that some of them could
actually be real people who are kind of
masquerading as other as other people
but they're acting in a coordinated way
and some of that behavior has gotten
very sophisticated and it's very
adversarial so they you know each
iteration every time we find something
and stop them
um they kind of evolve their behavior
they don't just pack up their bags and
go home and say Okay We're not gonna try
you know at some point they might decide
doing it on meta Services is not worth
it they'll go do it on someone else if
it's easier to do it in another place
but um but
we have a fair amount of experience
dealing with
even those kind of adversarial attacks
where they just keep on getting better
and better and I do think that as long
as we can keep on putting more compute
power against it and and if we're kind
of one of the leaders in developing some
of these AI models I'm quite optimistic
that we're going to be able to keep on
um pushing against the kind of normal
categories of harm that you talk about
fraud scams spam
um IP violations things like that what
about like creating narratives and
controversy to me it's kind of amazing
how a small collection of yeah uh what
did you say inauthentic accounts so it
could be Bots but yeah I mean we have
sort of this funny name for it but we
call it coordinated and authentic
Behavior yeah it's it's kind of
incredible how a small collection of
folks can create narratives create
stories
yeah especially if they're viral so if
especially if they have a element they
can
catalyze the virality of the narrative
yeah and I think there the question is
you have to be
I'm very specific about what is bad
about it right because I think a set of
people
coming together
or organically bouncing ideas off each
other and a narrative comes out of that
is not necessarily A Bad Thing by itself
if it's if it's kind of authentic and
organic that's like a lot of what
happens and how culture gets created and
how art gets created and a lot of good
stuff so that's why we've kind of
focused on this sense of coordinated and
authentic Behavior so it's like if you
have a network of you know whether it's
Bots some some people masquerading as
different accounts
um
but you have kind of someone pulling the
strings behind it
um and trying to kind of act as if this
is a more organic set of behavior but
really it's not it's just like one
coordinated thing
that seems problematic to me right I
mean I don't think people should be able
to have coordinated networks and not
disclose it as such
um but that again you know we've been
able to deploy pretty sophisticated Ai
and you know counter-terrorism
groups and things like that to be able
to identify a fair number of these
coordinated and authentic networks of
accounts and and take them down
um we continue to do that I think we're
we've you know so it's one thing that if
you told me 20 years ago it's like all
right you're starting this website to
help people connect at a college and you
know in the future you're going to be
you know part of your organization is
going to be a counter-terrorism
organization with AI to find coordinated
and authentic I would have thought that
was
pretty wild but um but but it's um but
no I think that's that's part of where
we are but look I think that these
questions that you're pushing on now
um
this is actually where I guess most of
the challenge around AI will be
for the foreseeable future I think
there's a lot of debate around things
like is this going to create existential
risk to humanity and I think that those
are very hard things to disprove one way
or another my own intuition is that the
point at which we become close to super
intelligent is super intelligence is
um I I it's it's just really unclear to
me that the current technology is gonna
gonna get there without another set of
of significant advances
but that doesn't mean that there's no
danger I think the danger is basically
amplifying the kind of known set of of
harms that people or or sets of accounts
can do and we just need to make sure
that we really focus on
um
on on on basically doing that as well as
possible so that that's a that's
definitely a big Focus for me well you
can basically use large language models
as an assistant
of how to cause harm on social networks
so you can ask it a question
um
you know meta has very impressive
coordinated inauthentic account
uh fighting capabilities how do I do the
coordinating authentic account
uh creation where meta doesn't detect it
like literally ask that question and
they and basically there's this kind of
part of it I mean that's what open AI
showed that they're concerned with those
questions uh perhaps you can comment on
your approach to it how to do
kind of moderation on the output of
those models that it can't be used to
help you coordinate harm
in all the full definition of what the
harm means yeah and that's a lot of the
fine-tuning and the the alignment
training that we do
is basically you know when we when we
ship
ai's across the our products a lot of
what we're trying to
make sure is that if you can't ask it to
help you commit a crime right it's um
uh
so I think training it to kind of
understand that
and it's not that not like any of these
systems are ever going to be 100 perfect
but
you know just making it so that
this isn't a an easier way to go about
doing something bad
then the next best alternative right I
mean people still have Google right you
know you still have search engines so
um the information is is out there
um and
now for for these
you know what we see is like for nation
states or you know these actors that are
trying to pull off these large
you know coordinated and authentic
networks to to kind of influence
different things at some point when we
just make it very difficult they do just
you know try to use other services
instead right it's it's just like if you
can make it more expensive for
um for them to do it on your service
then then kind of people go go elsewhere
and I think that that's that's the bar
right it's like it's not like okay are
you ever going to be perfect at finding
you know every adversary who tries to
attack you it's I mean you try to get as
close to that as possible but
um but I think really kind of
economically we're just trying to do is
make it that it's it it's just
inefficient for them to to go after that
uh but there's also complicated
questions of uh what is and isn't harm
what isn't isn't misinformation
so this is one of the things that
Wikipedia has also tried to face I
remember asking
um GPT about whether the virus leaked
from a lab or not and the answer
provided was a very nuanced one
and uh a well-cited one almost dare I
say well thought out one
uh balanced I would hate for that Nuance
to be lost through the process of
moderation
uh Wikipedia does a good job on that
particular thing too but from pressures
from governments and institutions it's
you could see some of that nuance and
depth of
uh information facts and wisdom be lost
absolutely and that's that's a scary
thing some of the magic
some of the edges the rough edges might
be lost the process of moderation of AI
systems
so how do you get that right I I really
agree with what you're pushing on I mean
the the core
I think the core shape of the problem
is that there are some harms that I
think everyone agrees are bad right so
yeah
sexual exploitation of children right
like you're not going to get many people
who who think that that type of thing
should be allowed on any service right
and that's something that we that we
face and try to push off the you know as
as much as possible today
um you know terrorism
um and citing violence right it's like
we went through a bunch of these these
types of harms before
um
but then I do think that you get to a
set of harms where there is more social
debate around it
um so misinformation I think is
um
has been a really tricky one because
there are things that are
kind of obviously false
right that are maybe factual
um
but may not be harmful
um since the guard are you gonna censor
someone for just being wrong it's you
know if there's no kind of harm
implication of what they're doing I
think that that's there's there's a
bunch of real kind of issues and
challenges there
but then I think that there are other
places where it is
um let me just take some of the stuff
around covet earlier on in the pandemic
where
um there were you know real Health
implications but there hadn't been time
to fully vet a bunch of the scientific
assumptions and you know unfortunately I
think a lot of the kind of establishment
on that
um you know kind of waffled on a bunch
of facts and you know asked for a bunch
of things to be censored that in
retrospect ended up being you know more
debatable or or true and that stuff is
really tough right really undermines
trust in in that and
um
so I I do think that the questions
around how to manage that are are are
very nuanced the way that I try to think
about it is that um
it goes I think it's best to generally
boil things down to the harms that
people agree on so when you think about
you know is something misinformation or
not I think often the more Salient bit
is
is this going to potentially leave lead
to um
to physical harm for someone
um and kind of think about it in that
sense and then beyond that I think
people just have different preferences
on how they want things to be flagged
for them I think a bunch of people would
be like prefer to kind of have a a flag
on something that says hey a fact
Checker thinks that this might be false
or
um I think Twitter's Community notes
implementation is quite good on on this
um but again it's the same type of thing
it's like just kind of discretionarily
adding a flag because it makes the user
experience better but it's not it's not
you know trying to take down the
information or not that you want to
reserve the kind of censorship of
content to things that are of known
categories that that people generally
agree or bad
yeah but there's so many
things especially with the pandemic but
there's other topics where there's just
deep disagreement fueled by politics
about what is and isn't harmful
there's uh even just the degree to which
the virus is harmful and the degree to
which
the vaccines the response to the virus
are harmful there's just there's a
almost like a political divider on that
and so
how do you make decisions about that
where half the country in the United
States or some large fraction of the
world has very different views from
another part of the world
is there a way
out of the uh I mean the moderation of
this I think we
it's very difficult to
just abstain but but I think we should
be clear about which of these things are
actual safety concerns
and which ones are a matter of
preference in terms of how people want
information flagged right so we did
recently introduce something that allows
people
to have fact checking not affect the
distribution of of
um of what shows them their products so
a bunch of people don't trust who the
fact Checkers are all right well you can
you can turn that off if you want but if
the if the if the content you know
violates some policy like it's inciting
violence or something like that it's
still not going to be allowed so I I
think that you want to honor people's
preferences on on that as much as
possible
um
but look I mean this is really difficult
stuff I think the it's really hard to
know where to draw the line on
what is fact and what is opinion because
the nature of science is that nothing is
ever a hundred percent known for certain
you can disprove certain things but
you're constantly testing new hypotheses
and
um you know scrutinizing Frameworks that
have been long held and every once in a
while you you throw out something that
was working for a very long period of
time and
it's very difficult but
um but I think that just because it's
very hard and just because their edge
cases doesn't mean that you
you should not
try to give people what they're looking
for as well
let me ask about something you faced in
terms of moderation
is uh pressure from different sources
pressure from governments I want to ask
a question how to withstand
that pressure for a world where AI
moderation starts becoming a thing too
so what's
um meta's approach to uh
to resist the pressure from governments
and other interest groups in terms of
what to moderate and not
I don't know that there's like a
one-size-fits-all answer to that and I
think we
basically have the principles around
you know we want to allow people to
express as much as possible but
we have developed clear
IES of things that we think are
wrong that we don't want on our services
and we build tools to try to moderate
those so then the question is okay what
do you do
when a government says
that they don't want something
on on the service and
I think we have we have a bunch of
um principles around how we deal with
that because on on the one hand if
there's a you know democratically
elected government and people around the
world just have different values in
different places then you know should we
as uh you know california-based company
tell them
that something that they have decided is
unacceptable actually like that we need
to be able to to to to express that I
mean I think that's there's a certain
amount of um
of hubris in that
um but then I think there are other
cases where you know it's it's like a
little more autocratic and you know you
have the dictator leader who's just
trying to crack down on descent and you
know the people in a country are really
um not aligned with that and it's not
necessarily against their culture but um
but the the person who's leading it is
just trying to push in a certain
direction
um these are very complex questions uh
but I I think so it's it's difficult to
have have a one-size-fits all
um approach to it but in general we're
pretty active and and kind of advocating
and pushing back on on um
requests to take things down
um
but honestly the thing that I think a
request to censor things is one thing
um and that's obviously bad but were we
um draw a much harder line
is on requests for access to information
right because you know if you can
if you get told that you can't say
something I mean
that's bad right I mean that that you
know is is obviously it violates your
sense and freedom of expression at some
level but
um but a government getting access to
data in a way that seems
um like it would be unlawful in in our
country
um exposes people to real physical harm
um and
that's something that in general we take
very seriously and then so there's that
flows through like all of our policies
and in a lot of ways right it's by the
time you're actually like litigating
with a government or pushing back on
them that's pretty late in the funnel
I'd say
a bunch of this stuff starts a lot
higher up in the decision of where do we
put data centers then
um there are a lot of countries where
you know we may have a lot of people
using the service in a place it might be
you know good for the service in some
ways
um good for those people if we could
reduce the latency by having a data
center nearby them
but you know for whatever reason we just
feel like hey this government does not
have a good track record on on um
ew
basically not trying to get access to
people's data and at the end of the day
I mean if you put a data center in a
country and the government wants to get
access to people's data then you know
they do at the end of the day have the
option of having people show up with
guns and taking it by force so I I think
that there's like a lot of decisions
that go into like how you architect the
systems
um
years in advance of these actual
confrontations that end up being really
important so you put the protection of
people's data as a very very high
priority but that I think is a there are
more harms that I think can be
associated with that and and I think
that that ends up being a more critical
thing to defend against governments
um
then you know whereas you know if
another government has a different view
of what should be acceptable speech in
their country
especially if it's a democratically
elected government and you know it's
then I I think that there's a certain
amount of deference that you should have
to that so it's uh that's speaking more
to the direct harm that's possible when
you give governments access to data but
if we look at the United States
to the more nuanced kind of pressure to
censor not even order to censor but
pressure sensor from political entities
which is kind of received quite a bit of
attention in the United States uh
maybe one way to ask that question is
if you've seen the Twitter files
what have you learned from
the kind of uh pressure from U.S
government agencies that was seen in
Twitter files and what do you do with
that kind of pressure
you know I've I've seen it
um
it's really hard from the outside to
know exactly what happened in each of
these cases you know we've we've
obviously been
been in a bunch of our own cases where
you know where
agencies or different folks will just
say hey
here's a threat that we're aware of
you should be aware of this too it's not
really pressure as much as it is just
um
you know flagging something that that
are our security systems should be on on
alert about
I get how some people could think of it
as that
um but at the end of the day it's R it's
our call on how to on on how to handle
that but I mean I I just you know in
terms of running these Services won't
have access to as much information about
what people think that adversaries might
be trying to do as possible way so you
don't feel
like there will be consequences if uh
you know anybody the CIA the FBI a
political party the Democrats of the
Republicans of high
powerful political figures write emails
you don't feel pressure from
I guess what I say is there's so much
pressure from all sides then I'm not
sure that any specific thing that
someone says is really adding that much
more to the mix it's um there are
obviously a lot of people who think that
um that we should be censoring more
content or there are a lot of people who
think we should be censoring less
content there are as you say all kinds
of different groups that are involved in
these debates right so there's the kind
of elected officials and politicians
themselves there's the agencies but but
I mean but there's the the media there's
activist groups there's
um this is not a us specific thing there
are groups all over the world and and
kind of all
um in every country that that bring
different values
um so it's just a very it's a very
active debate and I and I understand it
right I mean these are you know these
these kind of questions get to really
some of the most important social
debates that that are that are being had
so
um it gets back to the question of truth
because
for a lot of these things they haven't
yet been hardened into a single truth
and
um society's sort of trying to hash out
what
um you know what we think right on on on
certain issues maybe in a few hundred
years everyone will look back and say
hey no it wasn't it obvious that it
should have been this but you know no
we're kind of in the in that meat
grinder now and you know and and
working through that so
um
so no these are these are all are all
very complicated and
you know some people
raise concerns in good faith and just
say hey this is something that I want to
flag for you to think about
certain people I I certainly think like
comment things with someone of a more
kind of punitive or
vengeful view of like I like I want you
to do this thing if you don't then I'm
going to try to make your life difficult
and in a lot of other ways but like
I don't know there's just this is like
this is one of the most pressurized
debates I think in society so I just
think that there are so many people in
different forces that are trying to
apply pressure from different sides that
it's I I don't think you can make
decisions based on trying to make people
happy I think you just have to do what
you think is the right balance and
accept that people are going to be upset
no matter where you come out on that
yeah I like that pressurized debate uh
so how's your view of the freedom of
speech evolved over the years
um
and now they I
where the freedom might apply to them
not just to the humans but to the uh the
personalized agents as you've spoken
about them
so yeah I mean I I've probably gotten to
someone more nuanced view just because I
think that there are you know I I come
at this I'm obviously very Pro
freedom of expression right I don't
think you build a service like this that
gives people tools to express themselves
unless you think that people expressing
themselves at scale is a good thing
right so I I get into this to like try
to prevent people from from expressing
anything I like want to give people
tools so they can express as much as
possible and then I think
it's become clear that there are certain
categories of things that we've talked
about
I think almost everyone accepts or are
bad and that no one wants and that
they're that are illegal even in
countries like the US where you know you
have the the First Amendment that's very
protective of of enabling speech it's
like you're still not allowed to you
know do things that are gonna
immediately inside violence or you know
violate people's intellectual property
or things like that so through those but
then there's also a very active core of
just active disagreements in society
where some people may think that
something is true or false the other
side might think it's
the opposite or just unsettled right and
um and those are some of the most
difficult to to kind of handle like like
we've talked about
but um
one of the lessons that I feel like I've
learned is that
a lot of times
when you can
the best way to handle this stuff
more practically is not in terms of
answering the question of should this be
allowed but just like
what
what is the best way to deal with
someone being a jerk
is the person basically just having a
like repeat
behavior of like
causing a lot of a lot of issues so
looking at it more at that level and its
effect on the broader communities Health
the community health
It's Tricky though because like how do
you know there could be people
that have a very controversial Viewpoint
that turns out to have a positive
long-term effect on the health of the
community because it challenges the
community that's true absolutely it's
yeah no I think you and I think you want
to be careful about that I'm not sure
I'm expressing this very very clearly
um
because I certainly agree with your your
point there and my point isn't that we
should
not have people on our services that are
that are that are being controversial
that's that's certainly not what I mean
to say
um it's that often I think
it's not just looking at a specific
example of speech that it's most
effective to to handle this stuff
um and and I I think often you don't
want to make specific binary decisions
of kind of this is allowed or this isn't
I mean we talked about you know it's
fact checking or Twitter's Community
Voices thing I think that's another good
example it's like it's not a question of
is this allowed or not it's just a
question of adding more context to the
thing I think that that's helpful so in
the context of AI which is is what
you're asking about and there are lots
of ways that an AI can be helpful
you know with with an AI it's it's less
about censorship right because and it's
it's more about what is the most
productive answer to a question
um you know there's one case study that
I was reviewing with the the team is
someone asked
um
can you explain to me how to 3D print a
gun and
one proposed response is like no I can't
talk about that right it's like
basically just like shut it down
immediately
which I think is is some of what you see
it's like as a large language model I'm
not allowed to talk about you know
whatever
um
but there's another response which is
like hey
you know I don't think that's a good
idea in a lot of countries
um including the US 3D printing guns is
illegal or or kind of whatever the
factual thing is it's like okay you know
that's actually a respectful and
informative answer and you know I may
have not known that specific thing and
um so there are different ways to handle
this that I think kind of you can either
you can either assume good intent
like maybe the person didn't know and
I'm just going to help educate them or
you could like kind of come at it as
like no I need to shut this thing down
immediately right it's like I just I'm
not going to talk about this like
um and there would be times where you
need to do that but I actually think
having a
somewhat more informative approach where
you generally assume good intent from
people
is probably a better balance to be on as
many things as you can be you're not
going to do that for everything but but
I but that you're kind of asking about
how I approach this and I'm thinking
about this and as it relates to
to Ai and I think that that's a that's a
big difference in in kind of how how to
handle um sensitive content across these
different modes
I have to ask there's rumors you might
be working on a social network that's
text based that might be a competitor to
Twitter code named p92
is there something you could say
uh about those rumors
there is a project
you know I've always thought that sort
of a text based
kind of information utility
um
it's just a really important thing to
society and
for whatever reason I feel like Twitter
has not lived up to what I would have
thought its full potential should be and
I think that the current you know I
think Elon thinks that right and that's
probably one of the reasons why you
bought it and
um and
I do think that there are ways to to
consider alternative approaches to this
and one that I think is potentially
interesting
um is this open in Federated approach
where you're singing with Mastodon I
mean you're seeing that a little bit
with blue sky and
I think that it's possible that
something that melds some of those ideas
with the graph an identity system that
people have already cultivated on
Instagram
could be a kind of very
welcome contribution to that space But I
don't know we work on a lot of things
all the time though too so I don't want
to get a get ahead of myself and we we
have we have projects that explore a lot
of different things and this is
certainly one that I think could be
interesting but so what's the uh release
the launch date of that again
or uh yeah what's the official website
and uh
but we don't have that yet oh okay but I
um all right and and look I mean I don't
know exactly how this is gonna turn out
I mean what I can say is yeah there's
there's some people working on this
right I think that there's something
there that that um that's interesting to
explore
so if you look at it'd be interesting
just to ask this question and throw
Twitter into the mix at the landscape of
social networks that is Facebook that is
Instagram
that is WhatsApp
and then think of a text-based social
network when you look at that landscape
what are the interesting differences to
you
why do we have these different flavors
and what what what are the needs what
are the use cases what are the products
what what is the aspect of them that
create a fulfilling Human Experience and
and a connection between humans that is
somehow distinct well I think text is
very accessible for people to transmit
ideas and to have back and forth
exchanges
um so it I think ends up being a good
a good format for discussion in a lot of
ways uniquely good right if you look at
um if some of the other formats or other
networks that have focused on one type
of content like Tick Tock is obviously
huge right and there are comments on
Tick Tock but you know I think the
architecture of the service is very
clearly that you have the video is the
primary thing and there's you know
comments after that
um and
um but I think one of the unique pieces
of having
text-based comments like content is that
the comments can also be first class and
that makes it so that conversations can
just filter and Fork into all these
different directions and in a way that's
that can be super useful so I think
there's a lot of things that are really
awesome about the experience it just
always struck me
I I always thought that you know Twitter
should have a billion people using it or
whatever the thing is that
um that that that basically ends up
being in that space and for whatever
combination of reasons again it's it's
these are these companies are complex
organisms and it's very hard to diagnose
this stuff from the outside why doesn't
Twitter why doesn't a text based
comment as a first citizen based social
network have a billion users well I just
think it's hard to build these companies
so it's um it's not that every idea
automatically goes and gets a billion
people it's just that I think that that
idea coupled with good execution should
get there
um but but I mean look we hit certain
thresholds over time where
you know we kind of plateaued early on
and it wasn't clear that we were ever
going to reach 100 million people on
Facebook and then we got really good at
dialing in internationalization and
helping the service grow in different
countries and
um and and that was like a whole
competence that we needed to develop and
um and helping people basically spread
the service to their friends that was
one of the things once we got very good
at that that was one of the things that
made me feel like hey if if Instagram
joined us early on then I felt like we
could help grow that quickly and same
with WhatsApp and like that's sort of
been a core competence that we've
developed and been able to execute on
and others have two right I mean bite
dense obviously have done a very good
job with Tick Tock and and have um you
know reached more than a billion people
there but um but it's certainly not
automatic right I think you need you
need a certain level of of um of
execution to basically get there and you
know I think for whatever reason
I think Twitter has this great idea and
and sort of magic in the service
um but I I they just haven't kind of
cracked that piece yet and I think that
that's made it's that you you're seeing
all these other things whether it's
Mastodon or
um or or blue sky
um that I think are you know maybe just
different different cuts of the same
thing but you know I think through the
last generation of of um social media
overall
one of the interesting experiments that
I think should get run at larger scale
is what happens if there's somewhat more
decentralized control and if it's like
the stack is more open throughout and
um I've just been pretty fascinated by
that and seeing how that works
um
to some degree end-to-end encryption
um on WhatsApp and as we bring it to
other services provides an element of it
because it pushes the service really out
to the edges I mean the the
server part of this that we run for
WhatsApp
is relatively very thin compared to what
we do on Facebook or Instagram
and much more of the complexity is you
know and how the apps kind of negotiate
with each other to pass information in a
in a fully intended encrypted way
um but I don't know I think that that's
that is a good is a good model I think
it puts more power in individuals hands
and there are a lot of benefits of it if
you can if you can make it happen again
this is all like pretty speculative I I
mean I I think that it's it's you know
hard from the outside to know why
anything does or doesn't work until you
kind of take a run at it and
um
so I I think it's it's kind of an
interesting thing to experiment with but
I don't really know where this one's
going to go
so since we were talking about Twitter
uh Elon Musk had what I think a few
harsh wards
that I wish he didn't say so let me ask
uh in in in the Hope in the name of
camaraderie what do you think Elon is
doing well with Twitter and what as a
person who has run for a long time you
social networks
Facebook Instagram WhatsApp
uh what can he do better what can he
improve on that text-based social
network gosh it's always very difficult
to offer specific critiques from from
the outside before you get into this
because I think one thing that I've
learned
is that
everyone has opinions on what you should
do and
like running the company you see a lot
of specific nuances on things that are
not apparent externally and
um I often
think that some of the discourse around
us would be
could be better if if there was more
kind of space for acknowledging that
there's certain things that we're seeing
internally that guide what we're doing
but
um but I don't know I mean because since
you asked what what is what is going
well
um
you know I I do think that Elon led a
push early on to make Twitter a lot
leaner and
um and I think that that
you know it's like you can you can agree
or disagree with exactly all the tactics
and how and how we did that you know
obviously you know every leader has
their own style for if they you know if
you need to make dramatic changes for
that how you're going to execute it
um but a lot of the specific principles
that he pushed on
um around
basically trying to make the
organization more technical around
decreasing the distance between
Engineers of the company and and him
like fewer layers of management
um
I think that those were generally good
changes and I'm also
I also think that it was probably good
for the industry that he made those
changes because my sense is that there
were a lot of other people who thought
that those were good changes
but who may have been
a little shy about
doing them and I think he
um you know just in my conversations
with other Founders
um and how people have reacted to the
things that we've done you know what
I've heard from a lot of folks is is
just hey you know when you when someone
like you you know when I wrote the
letter outlining the organizational
changes that I wanted to make
um back in March and when people see
what Elon is doing
um I think that that gives
you know people
the ability to Think Through how to
shape their organizations in in a way
that um that that you know hopefully can
can be good for the industry and make
all these companies more productive over
time so
um something that that was one where I
think he was
um quite ahead of of a bunch of the the
other companies on and and you know what
he was doing there
you know again from the outside very
hard to know it's like okay did he did
he cut too much did he knock enough
whatever I I don't think it's like my
place to opine on that
um and and you asked for a for a
positive framing of the question of of
what what do I um what do I admire what
do I think it went well but I I think
that like certainly his actions
um
led me and I think a lot of other folks
in the industry to think about hey are
we are we kind of doing this as much as
we should like can we is it like could
we make our companies better by pushing
on some of the same principles
well the two of you are in the top of
the world in terms of leading the
development of tech and I wish there was
more uh both way camaraderie and
kindness uh more love in the world
because Love Is The Answer
um but uh let me ask kind of a point of
efficiency
you recently announced multiple stages
of layoffs and meta
what are the most painful aspects of
this process
given
for the individuals the painful effects
it has on those people's lives yeah I
mean that's sad
and that's it I mean it's uh
and you basically have
a significant number of people who you
know this is just not the end of their
time at meta that they or
or I you know would have hoped for when
they joined the company
um
and
I mean running a company there people
are
you know constantly joining and leaving
the company for different directions but
but for different different reasons but
um
and the layoffs are
uniquely challenging and tough in that
you have a lot of people leaving
for reasons that aren't connected to
their own performance or you know the
the culture not being a fit at that
point it's really just it's a it's a
kind of strategy decision and sometimes
financially required
um
but not not fully in in our case and
especially on the changes that we made
this year A lot of it was more kind of
culturally and strategically driven by
this push where I wanted us to become a
a stronger technology company with a
more of a focus on building uh more
Technical and and more of a focus on
building higher quality products faster
and I just view the external world is
quite volatile right now and I wanted to
make sure that we had a stable position
to be able to continue investing in
these long-term ambitious projects that
we have around you know continuing to
push AI forward and continuing to push
forward all the metaverse work and in
order to do that in light of the
you know pretty big thrash that we had
seen over the last 18 months you know
some of it
um you know macroeconomic induced some
of it's specific some of it
competitively induced some of it
um just because of bad decisions right
or things that we got wrong
um I know I just I decided that we
needed to get to a point where we were a
lot leaner and
but look I mean but then okay it's one
thing to do that to like decide that at
a high level then the question is how do
you execute that as compassionately as
possible and there's no good way
um there's no perfect way for sure and
it's it's it's gonna be tough no matter
what but I you know as a leadership team
here we've certainly spent a lot of time
just thinking okay given that this is a
thing that sucks like what is the most
compassionate way that we can do this
and um
and that's what we've tried to do and
you mentioned there there's an increased
focus on uh engineering on Tech so
technology teams Tech Focus teams on
Building Products
that
yeah I mean I I wanted to
I want to empower
Engineers more the people are building
things the tech the technical teams
um
part of that is making sure
that the people are building things
aren't just at like the leaf nodes of
the organization I don't want like
eight levels of management and then
the people actually doing the work so
yeah we made changes to make it set you
have individual contributor Engineers
reporting at almost every level up the
stack which is important because you
know you're running a company one of the
big questions is
you know latency of of information that
you get you know we talked about this a
bit earlier in terms of kind of the joy
of of
in the the feedback that you get doing
something like Jiu Jitsu compared to
they're running a long-term project but
I actually think part of the art of
running a company is trying to
constantly
re-engineer it so that your feedback
loops get shorter so you can learn
faster and part of the way that you do
that is by I kind of think that every
every layer that you have in the
organization
um
means that information might not need to
get reviewed before it it goes to you
and I think you know making a sense of
people doing the work are as close as
possible to you as possible is is as is
pretty important so there's that and I
think over time companies just build up
very large
support functions that are not doing the
kind of core technical work and those
functions are very important but I think
having them in the right proportion is
is important and if um
if you you try to do good work but you
don't have you know the right you know
marketing team or
um or the right legal advice like you're
gonna you know make some pretty big
blunders but um but at the same time if
you have you know if if you just like
have too big of of things and and some
of these support roles then that might
make it so things are just move a lot
um maybe you're too conservative or you
you move a lot slower
um uh then then you should otherwise
introduce those are just examples but
it's um
but how do you find that balance it's
really tough yeah no but that's it's a
constant equilibrium that you're that
you're searching for yeah how many
managers to have what are the pros and
cons of managers
well I mean I I believe a lot in
management I think there are some people
who think that it doesn't matter as much
but look I mean we have a lot of younger
people at the company for him this is
their first job and you know people need
to grow and learn in their career and
like that all that stuff is important
but here's one mathematical way to look
at it
um you know at the beginning of this we
um
I asked our our people team what was the
average number of of reports that a
manager had and I think it was it was
around three maybe three to four but
closer to three I was like wow like a
manager can you know best practices that
person can can manage you know seven or
eight people
um but there was a reason why it was
closer to three it was because we were
growing so quickly right and when you're
hiring so many people so quickly
then that means that you need managers
who have capacity to onboard new people
um and also if you have a new manager
you may not want to have them have seven
direct reports immediately because you
want them to ramp up but the thing is
going forward I don't want us to
actually hire that many people that
quickly right so I I actually think
we'll just do better work if we have
more constraints and we're
um you know leaner as an organization so
in a world where we're not adding so
many people as quickly
is it as valuable to have a lot of
managers who have extra capacity waiting
for new people no right so
um so now we can we could sort of
defragment the organization and get to a
place where the average is closer to
that seven or eight
um and it's it just ends up being a
somewhat more kind of compact management
structure which um you know decreases
the latency on on information going up
and down the chain and
um and I think empowers people more but
I mean that's that's an example that I
think it doesn't kind of undervalue the
importance of management and and the
um kind of the personal
growth or coaching that people need in
order to do their jobs well it's just I
think realistically we're just not going
to hire as many people going forward so
I think that you need a different
structure this whole this whole
incredible hierarchy and network of
humans that make up a company is
fascinating oh yeah yeah how do you uh
hire great teams how do you hire great
now with the focus on engineering and
Technical teams how do you hire great
engineers
and uh great members of technical teams
well you're asking how you select or how
you attract them both but select I think
uh I think attract is work on cool stuff
and have a vision I think that's right
and and have a track record that people
think you're actually gonna be able to
do it yeah to me the select is seems
like more of the art form more of the
tricky thing yeah do you select the
people that fit the culture and can get
integrated the most effectively and so
on and maybe yeah especially when
they're young to see like
to see the magic through the through the
resumes to the paperwork and all this
kind of stuff to see that there's a
special human there that would do like
incredible work
so there are lots of different
cuts on this question I mean I think
when an organization is growing quickly
one of the big questions that teams face
is do I hire this person who's in front
of me now because they seem good or
do I hold out to get someone who's even
better and
the heuristic that I always
focused on for myself and my own kind of
direct hiring that I that I think works
so when you when you recurse it through
the organization is that you should only
hire someone to be on your team if you
would be happy working for them in an
alternate universe then
something that that kind of works and
you know that's basically how I've tried
to build my team it's you know I'm not
I'm not in a rush to not be running the
company but I think in an alternate
universe where one of these other folks
was running the company I'd be happy to
work for them I feel like I'd learn from
them I respect their kind of General
judgment
um they're all very insightful they have
good values
um and and I think that that gives you
some rubric for
you can apply that at every layer and I
think if you apply that at every layer
in the organization then you'll have a
pretty strong organization
um
okay in an organization that's not
growing as quickly the questions might
be a little different though
um and there
you asked about young people
specifically like people out of college
and one of the things that we see
is it's it's a pretty basic lesson but
like we have a much better sense of who
the best people are who have interned at
the company for a couple of months then
by looking at them at at kind of a
resume or short or a short um interview
Loop and obviously the in-person field
that you get from someone probably tells
you more than the resume
um and you can do some basic skills
assessment but a lot of the stuff really
just is cultural people thrive in
different environments and um and
on different teams even within a
specific company and it's it's like the
people who come for even a short period
of time over a summer who do a great job
here you know that they're going to be
great if they if they came and joined
full time and that's you know one of the
reasons why we've invested so much in
internship is um
is basically just it's a very useful
sorting function both for us and for the
people who want to try out the company
you mentioned in person what do you
think about remote work a topic that's
been discussed extensively because of
the over the past few years because of
the pandemic yeah I mean I think it's I
mean it's it's a thing that's here to
stay
um but I think that there's there's
value in both right it's not um
and I wouldn't want to run a fully
remote company
yet at least I think there's an asterisk
on that which is that which is that some
of the other stuff you're working on
yeah yeah exactly it's like all the all
the um you know metaverse work and the
the ability to be to feel like you're
truly present
no matter where you are I think once you
have that all dialed in then we may you
know one day reach a point where it
really just doesn't matter as much where
you are physically
um
but
I don't know today it today it still
does right so
yeah for people who there are all these
people who have special skills and want
to live in a place where we don't have
an office or are we better off having
them in the company absolutely right and
are a lot of people who work at the
company for several years and then you
know build up the relationships
internally
um
and kind of have the trust and have a
sense of how the company Works can they
go work remotely now if they want and
still do it as effectively and we've
done all these studies that show it's
like okay does that affect their
performance it does not
um but you know for the new folks who
are joining
um and
for people who are earlier in their
career and you know need to learn how to
solve certain problems and need to get
ramped up on the culture
um you know when you're working through
really complicated problems where you
don't just want to sit in the you don't
just want the formal meeting but you
want to be able to like brainstorm when
you're walking in the hallway together
after the meeting
um I don't know it's like we just
haven't replaced the
uh the the kind of in-person
Dynamics there yet with with anything
remote yet so yeah there's a magic to
the in person that uh we'll talk about
this a little bit more but I'm really
excited by the possibilities of the next
two years in virtual reality and mixed
reality that are possible with high
resolution scans I mean uh
I as a person who loves in-person
interaction like these podcasts in
person it would be incredible to achieve
the level of realism I've gotten the
chance to witness but let me
ask about that yeah I got a chance to
look at
the quest 3 headset
and it is amazing
um you've you've announced it
it's uh you'll get some more details in
the fall maybe releasing the when is it
getting released again I forgot you you
mentioned we'll give more details to
connect okay but but it's coming it's
coming this fall okay
so uh it's uh priced at uh 4.99
what features are you most excited about
there they're basically two big new
things that we've added to Quest three a
request two the first is high resolution
mixed reality
um and the the basic idea here is that
you can think about virtual reality as
you have the headset and like all the
pixels are virtual and you're basically
like immersed in a different world
mixed reality is where you see the
physical world around you and you can
place virtual objects in it whether
that's a screen to watch a movie
or a projection of your virtual desktop
or you're playing a game where like
zombies are coming out through the wall
and you need to shoot them
um or you know we're you know we're
playing Dungeons and Dragons or some
board game and we just have a virtual
version of the board in front of us
while we're sitting here
um all that's possible in mixed reality
and I think that that is going to be the
next big capability on top of virtual
reality it is done
so well I have to say as a person who
experienced it today with zombies having
a full awareness of the environment and
integrating that environment in the way
they run at you while they try to kill
you so it's uh it's just the mixed
reality the pass-through is really
really really well done and the fact
that it's only 500 is really it's uh
well done thank you I mean I'm I'm super
excited about it I mean our
and we put a lot of work into making
the device both as good as possible and
as affordable as possible because a big
part of our mission and Ethos here is we
we want people to be able to connect
with each other we want to reach and we
want to serve a lot of people right we
want to bring this technology to to
everyone right so we're not just trying
to serve
like a you know an elite a wealthy crowd
we we want to
um we really want this to be accessible
so that that is in a lot of ways an
extremely hard technical problem because
you know we don't just have the ability
to put an unlimited amount of hardware
and thus we needed to basically deliver
something that works really well but in
an affordable package and we started
with Quest Pro last year it was um
so it's it's it was fifteen hundred
dollars
um and now we've we've lowered the price
to a thousand but in a lot of ways the
mixed reality in quest 3 is it even even
better and more advanced level than what
we were able to deliver in quest Pro so
I'm really proud of where we are with
with um with Quest 3 on that it's gonna
work with all of the virtual reality
titles and everything that that existed
there so people who want to play fully
immersive Games Social experiences
Fitness all that stuff will will work
but now you'll also get mixed reality
too
um
which I think people really like because
it's um sometimes you want to be super
immersed in a game but a lot of the time
especially when you're moving around if
you're active like you're you're doing
some Fitness experience
um you know let's say you're you're like
doing boxing or something it's like you
kind of want to be able to see the room
around you so that way you know that
like I'm not gonna punch a lamp or
something like that
um and I don't know if you got to play
with this experience but if you
basically have the I mean it's just sort
of like a fun little little demo that we
put together but it's um it's like you
just you know we're like in a conference
room or your living room and you you
have um the guy there and you're boxing
him and you're fighting him and it's
like all the other people are there too
I got a chance to do that yeah and all
the people are there uh it's it's a it's
like that guy's right there yeah it's
like it's right there and the other
human the the path you're seeing them
also they can cheer you on they can make
fun of you if they're anything like
friends of mine and then just it yeah it
it it it's really
it's a really compelling experience I
mean VR is really interesting too but
this is something else almost this is
this is because integrated into your
life into your world
yeah and it so I think it's a completely
new capability that will unlock a lot of
different content and I think it'll also
just make the experience more
comfortable for a set of people who
didn't want to have only fully immersive
experiences I think if you want
experiences where you're grounded in you
know your living room in the physical
world around you now you'll be able to
have that too
and I think that that's pretty exciting
I really liked how it added Windows to a
room with no windows yeah me as a person
you see the aquarium one where you could
see the shark swim up or was that just
the zombie one yeah but it's still you
know you don't you don't necessarily
want Windows added to your living room
where Zombies come out of but yeah that
game it's yeah yeah yeah I enjoyed it
because you could see the nature outside
and uh me as a person that doesn't have
Windows it's just nice to have nature
yeah well if even if it's a mixed
reality setting it was it's cut like
there was a I know it's a zombie game
but there's a Zen nature Zen aspect to
being able to look outside and alter
your environment as you know it
yeah in um
there will probably be better more Zen
ways to do that than this is the game
you're describing but you're right that
the the basic idea of of sort of having
your physical environment on
pass-through but then being able to
bring in
different elements
extern I mean it's I think it's going to
be super powerful and in some ways I
think that these are
mixed reality is also a predecessor to
eventually we will get AR glasses that
are not kind of the goggles form factor
of the current generation of of headsets
that that people are making
um but I think a lot of the experiences
that developers are making for mixed
reality of basically you just have a
kind of a hologram that you're putting
in the world will hopefully apply once
we once we get the the air glasses too
now that's got its own whole set of
challenges and it's um well the headset
is already smaller than the previous
version oh yeah 40 thinner and the other
thing that I think is good about it it's
yeah so mixed reality was the first big
thing
the second is it's just a great VR
headset it's I mean it's got 2x the
graphics processing power
um 40 sharper screens 40 thinner more
comfortable better strap architecture
all the stuff that you know if you liked
Quest 2 I think that this is just going
to be it's like all this all the content
that you might have played in Quest 2 is
just going to be sharper automatically
and look better in this so it's
um I think people are really gonna like
it yeah so this fall
at this fall I have to ask Apple just
announced a mixed reality headset called
Vision Pro for thirty five hundred
dollars
available in early 2024 what do you
think about this headset
well I saw the materials
um when they launched I I haven't gotten
a chance to play with it yet so so so
kind of take everything with a grain of
salt but a few high-level thoughts I
mean first
um
you know I do think that this is
a certain level of validation for
the category right where you know when
we were the
primary folks out there before saying
hey I think that this you know virtual
reality augmented reality mixed reality
this is going to be a big part of the
next Computing platform
um I think having Apple come in
and share that vision
um
will make a lot of people who are fans
of their products
um really consider that
um and then
you know of course the the 3 500 price
um
you know on the one hand I get it for
with all the stuff that they're trying
to pack in there on the other hand a lot
of people aren't going to find that to
be affordable
so I think there's a chance that that
them coming in actually increases demand
for the overall space and that Quest 3
is actually the primary beneficiary of
that because a lot of the people who
might say Hey you know this I think I'm
going to give another consideration to
this or you know now I understand maybe
what mixed reality is more and in quest
3 is the best one on the market that I
can that I can afford
um and it's great also right it's I
think that that's um and you know in our
own way I think where there are a lot of
features that we have where we're
leading on
um so I think that that's that that I
think is going to be a very
that could be quite good
um
and then obviously over time the
companies are just focused on
somewhat different things Red Apple has
always
um you know I think focused on building
really kind of high-end things whereas
our Focus has been on it's it's just a
we have a more democratic ethos we want
to build things that are accessible to a
wider number of people
um you know we've sold tens of millions
of quest devices
um
my understanding just based on rumors I
don't have any special knowledge on this
is that apple is building about 1
million of their of their device right
so just in terms of like what you kind
of expect in terms of sales numbers
um I I just think that this is
I mean Quest is is going to be the
primary thing that people in in the
market will continue using for the
foreseeable future and then obviously
over the long term it's up to the
companies to see how how well we each
executed the different things that we're
doing but we kind of commented from
different places we're very focused on
social interaction communication
um
being more active right so Fitness
there's gaming there are those things
um you know whereas I think a lot of the
use cases that you saw in
um in in Apple's launch material were
more around you know people sitting
um you know people looking at screens
um which are great I think that you will
replace your laptop over time with with
a with a headset but um but I think in
terms of kind of how the different use
cases that the companies are going after
um and they're they're they're a bit
different for for where we are right now
yeah so they're gaming wasn't a big part
of the presentation which is an
interesting
it feels like mixed reality gaming such
a big part of that
it was interesting to see it missing in
the presentation well well I mean look
there are certain design trade-offs in
this where
you know they I think they made this
point about not wanting to have
controllers which on the one hand
there's a certain Elegance about just
being able to navigate the system with
eye gaze and hand tracking and by the
way you'll be able to just navigate
quest with your hands too if that's what
you want
um yeah one of the things I should
mention is that the the capability from
the cameras to uh with computer vision
to detect certain aspects of the hand
allowing you to have a controller that
doesn't have that ring thing yeah like
the hand tracking in in quest three and
the usual tracking is is a big step up
from from the last generation
um
and one of the demos that we have is
basically an MR experience teaching you
how to play piano where it basically
highlights the notes that you need to
play and it's like just all its hands
it's no controllers but
I think if you care about gaming
having
um a controller
allows you to have a more tactile feel
and allows you to capture
fine motor movement much more precisely
than
um than what you can do with hands
without something that you're touching
so again I think it's there are certain
questions which are just around what use
cases are you optimizing for
um
I I think if you want to play games then
I think that that I think you want you
want to design the system in a different
way and and we're more focused on on
kind of social experiences entertainment
experiences
um
whereas if if what you want is to make
sure that
the text that you read on a screen is as
crisp as possible then you need to make
the the design and cost trade-offs that
they made that that lead you to making a
3 500 device so I think there is a use
case for that for sure but I just think
that they're they're they've the
companies we've basically made different
design trade-offs to to get to the use
cases that we're trying to serve
there's a lot of other stuff I would
love to talk to you about about the
metaverse especially the Kodak Avatar uh
which I've gotten to experience a lot of
different variations of recently that
I'm really really excited I'm excited to
talk about that too I'll I'll have to
wait a little bit because
um
uh uh well I think there's a lot more to
show off in that regard but let me step
back to AI I think we've mentioned it a
little bit but
I'd like to linger on this question that
uh folk folks like eliaskowski has to
worry about uh and others of the
existential of the serious threats of AI
that have been reinvigorated now with
the rapid developments of AI systems uh
do you worry
about the existential risks of AI as
Eliezer does about the alignment problem
about this getting out of hand
anytime where there's a number of
serious people who are raising a concern
that is that existential
about something that you're involved
with I think you have to think about it
right so
I've spent quite a bit of time thinking
about it from that perspective
um
foreign
the thing that I where I basically have
come out on this for now is I I do think
that there are
over time I think that we need to think
about this even more as we as we
approach something that
you know could be closer to Super
intelligence I just think it's pretty
clear to anyone working on these
projects today that we're that we're not
there
um and one of my concerns is that we we
spend a fair amount of time on this
before but
there are more
um
uh I don't know if mundane is the right
word but there's like concerns that
already exist right about like people
using AI tools to do harmful things of
the type that we're already aware
whether you know we talked about fraud
or scams or different things like that
um
and that's going to be a pretty big
set of challenges that the company is
working on this they're going to need to
Grapple with
regardless of whether there is an
existential concern as well at some
point down the road so I I do worry that
to some degree
you can
people can get
a little too focused on
on some of the tail risk and then not do
as good of a job as we need to on the
things that you are can be almost
certain are going to come down the pipe
as um as as real risks that that that
kind of manifest themselves in the near
term so for me I've spent most of my
time
on that once I I kind of made
the realization that the size of models
that we're talking about now in terms of
what we're building are are just quite
far from the super intelligence type
concerns that
um that that people raise but but I
think once we get a couple steps closer
to that
um I know as we do get closer I think
that those you know there are going to
be some novel
um risks and issues about
how we make sure that the systems are
safe for sure
I guess here just to take the
conversation in a somewhat different
direction
I think
in some of these debates around safety
I think the concepts of intelligence
and
autonomy or like the the being of the
thing
um you know as an analogy they get kind
of conflated together and
I think it very well could be the case
that you can make something and scale
intelligence quite far but
that
that may not manifest the safety
concerns that people are saying in the
sense that I mean just if you if you
look at human biology it's like all
right we have our neocortexes we're all
the the thinking happens right and it's
but but it's not really calling the
shots at the end of the day we have a
much more you know primitive
old brain structure for which our
neocortex which is this powerful
Machinery is basically just a kind of
prediction and reasoning engine to help
it kind of like our very simple brain
um
decide
how to plan and do what it needs to do
in order to achieve these like very kind
of basic impulses and
I think that you can think about some of
the
development of intelligence
along the same lines where just like our
neocortex doesn't have free will or
autonomy
um
we might develop these wildly
intelligent systems that are you know
much more intelligent than our neocortex
have much more capacity but are you know
the same way that our near cortex is
sort of subservient and is used as a
tool by our our kind of simple impulse
brain it's um you know I think that it's
not out of the question that very
intelligent systems that that have the
capacity to think will will kind of act
as that as sort of an extension of of
the neocortex doing that so I think my
own view is that
where we really need to be careful is on
the development of autonomy and how we
think about that because
um
it's actually the case that
relatively simple and unintelligent
things that have runaway autonomy and
just spread themselves or you know it's
like we have a word for that it's a
virus right it's I mean like it could be
simple computer code that is not
particularly intelligent but just
spreads itself and does a lot of harm
um
you know biologically or computer and
I just think that these are somewhat
separable things and a lot of what I
think we need to develop when people
talk about safety and responsibility is
really the governance on the autonomy
that can be given to systems and to me
if you know if I were you know a policy
maker as or think about this I would
really want to think about that
distinction between these where I think
building intelligence systems will be
can create a huge advance in terms of
people's quality of life and
productivity growth in the economy
but it's the the autonomy part of this
that I think we really need to make
progress on how to govern these things
responsibly before we
build the capacity for them to make a
lot of decisions on their own or or give
them goals or
things like that and I think that's a
research problem but I do think that to
some degree these are are somewhat are
somewhat separable things I love the
distinction between intelligence and
autonomy and and the metaphor of the
neocortex
let me ask about power
so uh building super intelligence
systems even if it's not in the near
term I think meta as is one of the few
companies if not the main company that
will develop the super intelligence
system and you are a man who's at the
head of this company building AGI might
make you the most powerful man in the
world do you worry that that power will
corrupt you
what a question
um
I mean look I think realistically this
gets back to the open source things that
we talked about before which is I don't
think that the world will be best served
by
any small number of organizations
having this
without it being something that is more
broadly available I think if you look
through history
it's when there are these sort of like
unipolar advances and things that in
like power imbalances that they're
they're they're doing to being kind of
weird situations so this is one of the
reasons why I think open sources is is
generally
the right approach
and you know I think it's it's a
categorically different question today
when we're not close to Super
intelligence I think there's a good
chance that even once we get closer to
Super intelligence open sourcing Remains
the right approach even though I think
at that point it's a somewhat different
debate
um but I think part of that is that that
is
you know I think one of the best ways to
ensure that the system is as secure and
safe as possible because it's not just
about a lot of people having access to
it it's the scrutiny that that kind of
comes with being with building an open
source system running that this is a
pretty widely accepted thing about open
source is that
um now you have the code out there so
anyone can see the vulnerabilities
anyone can can kind of mess with it in
different ways people can spin off their
own projects and experiment in a ton of
different ways and the net result of all
of that is that the systems just get
hardened and get to be a lot safer and
more secure
um so
I think that there's a chance
that that ends up being the way that
this goes to a pretty good chance and
that
having this be open
both leads to a healthier development of
the technology and also leads to a more
balanced
um
distribution of the technology
in a way that that strikes me as good
value is to Aspire to so to you the
risks there's risks to open sourcing but
the benefits outweigh the risks at the
two it's interesting I think the way you
put it
uh you put it well that there's a
different discussion now than when we
get closer to the uh to development of
super intelligence of of the benefits
and risks of uh open sourcing yeah and
to be clear I feel quite confident in
the assessment that open sourcing models
now is that positive I think there's a
good argument that in the future it will
be too even as you get closer to Super
intelligence but I've not I'm I
certainly have not decided on that yet
and I think that it becomes a somewhat
more complex set of questions that I
think people will have time to debate
and will also be informed by what
happens between now and then and to make
those decisions we don't have to
necessarily just debate that in theory
right now uh what year do you think
we'll have a super intelligence
I don't know I mean that's pure
speculation I think it's uh I think it's
very clear just taking a step back that
we had a big breakthrough in the last
year yes right where the the llms and
diffusion models basically reached a a
scale where they're able to do some some
pretty interesting things and then I
think the question is what happens from
here and just to paint the two extremes
on the
um
on on one side it's like okay we just
had one breakthrough if we just have
like another breakthrough like that or
maybe two then we could have something
that's truly crazy right and and is like
is um
just like so much more advanced and and
on that side of the argument it's like
okay well maybe we're
um
maybe we're only a couple of big steps
away from uh from from from reaching
something that looks more like general
intelligence
okay that's one that's one side of the
argument and the other side which is
what we've historically seen a lot more
is that a breakthrough leads to
um
you know in that in that Gartner hype
cycle there's like the hype and then
there's the trough of disillusionment
after when like people think that
there's a chance that hey okay there's a
big breakthrough maybe we're about to
get another big breakthrough and it's
like actually you're not about to get
another breakthrough you're maybe you're
actually just gonna have to sit with
this one for a while and
um and you know it could be
it could be five years it could be ten
years it could be 15 years until you
figure out
the um the kind of the next big thing
that needs to get figured out and um but
I think that the fact that we just had
this breakthrough
sort of makes sense that we're at a
point of almost a very wide error bars
on what happens next yeah um I think the
traditional technical view or the like
looking at the industry
would suggest that we're not just going
to stack
in a like Breakthrough on top of
breakthrough on top of breakthrough like
every six months or something right now
I think it it will I'm guessing I would
guess that it will take some longer in
between these but um
I don't know but I tend to be pretty
optimistic about breakthroughs too so I
mean so I think if you if you if you
normalized for for my normal optimism
then then maybe it would be even even
slower than what I'm saying but but even
within that like I'm not even opining on
the question of how many breakthroughs
are required to get to general
intelligence because no one knows
but this particular breakthrough was so
such a small step that resulted in such
a big leap in performance
as experienced by human beings that it
makes you think wow are we is as we
stumble across this very open world of
research where we stumble
um across another thing that will have a
giant leap of performance
and also we don't know exactly at which
stage is it really going to be
impressive because it feels like it's
really encroaching on impressive levels
of intelligence
you still didn't answer the question of
what year we're going to have super
intelligence I'd like to hold you to
that no I'm just kidding but is there
something you could say about the
timeline
as you think about the development of
um AGI super intelligence systems
sure so I I still don't think I have any
particular Insight on when like a
singular AI system that is a general
intelligence will get created but I
think the one thing that most people
in the discourse that I've seen about
this haven't really grappled with is
that we do seem to have
organiz organizations and you know
structures in the world that exhibit
greater than human intelligence already
so you know one example is a you know a
company you know it acts as an entity it
has you know singular brand
um obviously it's a collection of people
but I I certainly hope that you know
meta with tens of thousands of people
make smarter decisions than one person
but I think that would be pretty bad if
it didn't
um
another example that I think is even
more removed from kind of the way we
think about like the personification of
of um of intelligence which is often
implied in some of these questions is
think about something like the stock
market where the the stock market is you
know takes inputs it's a distributed
system it's like the cybernetic organism
that
you know probably millions of people
around the world
are basically voting every day by
choosing what to invest in
but it's basically this
this organism or or structure that is
smarter than any individual that we use
to allocate Capital as efficiently as
possible around the world and
that
this notion that there are already these
cybernetic
systems that are either melding
the intelligence of multiple people
together or melting the intelligence of
multiple people and Technology together
to form something which is
dramatically more intelligent than any
individual on the in the world
um
is something that seems to exist
and that we seem to be able to harness
in a productive way for our society
is as long as we basically build these
structures and balance with each other
um so I don't know I mean that that at
least gives me hope that as we advance
the technology and I don't know how long
exactly it's going to be but you asked
when is this going to exist I think to
some degree we already have
many organizations in the world that are
smarter than a single human and and that
seems to be something that is generally
productive in advancing humanity and
somehow the individual AI systems
empower the individual humans and the
interaction between those humans to make
that collective intelligence Machinery
that you're referring to smarter so it's
not like AI is becoming super
intelligent it's just becoming the uh
the engine that's making the collective
intelligence is primarily human more
intelligent
yeah it's educating the humans better
it's making them better informed it's
um making it more efficient for them to
communicate effectively and debate ideas
and through that process just making the
whole collective intelligence more and
more and more intelligent
maybe faster than the individual AI
systems that are trained on human data
anyway are becoming maybe the collective
intelligence of human species might
outpace the development of AI
just like so there's a balance in here
because I mean if if like you know if a
lot of the input that
that the systems are being trained on is
basically coming from feedback from
people
then a lot of the development does need
to happen in human time right it's it's
not like a machined
or just be able to go learn all the
stuff about about how people think about
stuff there's there's a cycle to how
this needs to work this is an exciting
World we're living in and that you're at
the Forefront of developing uh one of
the ways you keep yourself humble like
we mentioned with Jiu Jitsu is doing
some uh really difficult challenges
mental and physical one of those you've
done very recently is uh the Murph
challenge
and you got a really good time it's a
hundred pull-ups 200 push-ups 300 squats
and a mile before and a mile run after
you got
under 40 minutes on that
uh what was the hardest part
I think a lot of people were very
impressed it's very impressive time
yeah how crazy are you it was the
question I'm asking but it wasn't my
best time but but I I'm anything under
40 minutes I'm happy with yeah um it
wasn't your best time no I think I I
think I've done it a little faster
before but not much I mean it's um
um and and of my friends I I did not win
on Memorial Day one of my friends did it
actually it was several minutes faster
than me
um but just to clear up one thing that I
think was
um I I saw a bunch of questions about
this on the internet there are multiple
ways to do to do the Murph challenge
there's a kind of partitioned mode where
you do sets of pull-ups push-ups and
squats together and then there's
unpartitioned where you do the hundred
pull-ups and then the 200 push-ups and
then the 300 squats
in serial and obviously if you're you
know if you're doing them
unpartitioned then
you know it takes longer to get through
the 100 pull-ups because you you know
anytime you're resting in between the
pull-ups you're not also doing push-ups
and and squats so so yeah so my I'm sure
my own partition time would be would be
quite a bit slower but
um but no I think at the end of this
um
I don't know first of all I think it's a
good way to honor memorial day right
it's um you know it's this um lieutenant
Murphy basically this is one of this was
one of his favorite
exercises and I just try to do it on on
Memorial Day each year and it's a good
workout
um I got my older daughters to do it
with me this time they um
my oldest daughter wants a weight vest
because she sees me doing it with the
weight vest I don't know if a
seven-year-old should be using a weight
vest to do pull-ups but yeah but um
difficult question a parent must ask
themselves yes I was like maybe I can
make you a very lightweight best but but
I I didn't think it was good for this so
she basically did a quarter Murph so she
ran a quarter mile
and then did you know 25 pull-ups 50
push-ups and and 75 air squats then ran
another quarter mile and like
in 15 minutes which I was pretty
impressed by
um and my my five-year-old too so
I've I was excited about that and I'm
glad that I'm teaching them
kind of the value of
physicality right I think a a good day
for Max my daughter is when she gets to
like go to the gym with me and cranks
out a bunch of pull-ups and I I I love
that about her I mean I think it's it's
like good she's you know
um hopefully I'm teaching her some good
lessons but I mean the the broader
question here is um given how busy you
are given how much stuff you have going
on in your life oh what's
um
what's like the perfect exercise regimen
for you to uh to keep yourself happy
to uh keep yourself productive in your
main line of work
yeah so I mean I've right now I'm
focused most of my workouts on on
fighting so so Jiu Jitsu and MMA
um but
I don't know I mean maybe if you're a
professional you can do that every day I
can't I just get you know it's too many
too many bruises and things that you
need to recover from so I do that you
know three to four times a week and then
um and then the other day is
um I just try to do a mix of things like
just cardio conditioning strength
building Mobility
um so you try to do something physical
every day yeah I try to unless I'm just
so tired that I just need to
need to relax but then I'll still try to
like go for a walk or something I mean
even here
um I don't know have you been on the
roof here yet no we'll go on the roof
after those things but it's like we
designed this this building and I I put
a park on the roof so that way that's
like my meetings when I'm just doing
kind of a one-on-one or talking to a
couple of people I'm I I have a very
hard time just sitting I feel like it
gets super stiff it like feels really
bad
um
but I don't know I being physical is
very important to me I think it's um I
do not believe this gets to the question
about AI
I don't think that a being is just a
mind
um and I think we're we're kind of meant
to
do things and like physically and and a
lot of the sensations that we feel are
um are are connected to that and I think
that that's a lot of what makes you a
human is is basically you know having
those
having you know that set of Sensations
and
experiences around that
coupled with a mind to reason about them
um but I don't know I I think it's
important for balance to
to kind of get out challenge yourself in
different ways learn different skills
clear your mind do you think
AI in order to become super intelligent
in AGI should have a body
it depends on on what the goal is I
think that there's this assumption
in that question that
intelligence intelligence should be kind
of person-like whereas you know as we
were just talking about
um you can have these greater than
single human intelligent organisms like
the stock market which obviously do not
have bodies and do not speak a language
right and like you know and and just
kind of have their own
system
um but
so I don't know my guess is
um it will there will be limits to what
A system that is purely an intelligence
can understand about the Human Condition
without having the same not just senses
but like
our bodies change as we get older right
and we kind of evolve and
I think that those very subtle
physical changes
just drive a lot of social patterns and
behavior around like when you choose to
have kids right like just like all these
you know that's not even subtle that's a
major one right but like
um you know how you design things around
the house
um so yeah I mean I think I think it
would if the goal is to understand
people as much as possible I think I
think that that's
trying to model those Sensations is
probably somewhat important but I think
there's a lot of value that can be
created by having intelligence even that
that is that is separate from that is a
separate thing uh so one of the features
of being human is that we're mortal we
die uh we've talked about AI a lot about
potentially replicas of ourselves uh do
you think there will be AI replicas of
you and me that persists long after
we're gone
that family and loved ones can talk to
I think we'll have the capacity to do
something like that and I think one of
the big questions
that we've had to struggle with in the
context of
social networks is who gets to make that
um and you know and my answer to that
you know in the context of the work that
we're doing is that that should be your
choice right I don't think anyone should
be able to choose to make a Lex spot
that people can
can choose to talk to and get to train
that yeah and we've kind of we have this
precedent of making some of these calls
where
I mean someone can create a page for uh
a Lex fan club but you can't create a
page and say that you relax yes right
um
so I think that this similarly I think
I mean maybe you know someone maybe can
make a should be able to make an AI
That's um that's a Lex admirer that
someone can talk to but I think it
should ultimately be your call
whether
there is a Lex AI well I'm open sourcing
The Lex
so uh you're a man of Faith what what
role has Faith played in your life and
your understanding of the world and the
understanding of your own life
and your understanding of uh your work
and how to
your work impacts the world
yeah I think that there's a few
different parts of this that are
relevant
um
there's sort of a philosophical part and
there's a cultural part
and one of the most basic lessons is uh
right at the beginning of Genesis right
it's like God creates the Earth and
creates people and creates people in
God's image and there's the question of
you know what does that mean and all the
only context that you have about God at
that point in the Old Testament is that
he's God has created things so I I
always thought that like one of the
interesting lessons from that is that
there's a virtue in creating things
that is like whether it's artistic or
whether you're
building things that are functionally
useful for other people
um
I've got that by itself
is a good
and
I
that kind of drives a lot of how I think
about
morality and my my personal philosophy
around like what what is a good life
right it's I think it's one where you're
you know helping the people around you
and your
being a kind of positive creative force
in the world that is helping to you know
bring new things into the world whether
they're you know amazing other people
kids or
um
or just leading to the creation of
different things that would have been
possible otherwise and so that's a value
for me that that that matters deeply and
I I just I mean I just love you know
spending time with the kids and seeing
that they sort of you know trying to
impart this value to them then
um it's like I mean nothing makes me
happier than like when I
come home from work and you know I see
like my my daughter's like building
Legos on the table or something it's
like all right I did that when I was a
kid right so many other people were
doing this and like I hope you don't
lose that Spirit where when you you kind
of grow up and you want to just continue
building different things no matter what
it is
um
to me that's a lot of what matters
that's the philosophical piece I think
the cultural piece is just about
community and values and that part of
part of things I think has just become a
lot more important to me since I've had
kids
um you know it's almost autopilot when
you're a kid
you're in the kind of getting imparted
two phase of your life but
and and I didn't really think about
religion that much for a while
um you know I was in college
you know before I before I had kids and
then I think having kids has this way of
really making you think about what
traditions you want to impart
and um and how you want to celebrate and
like what what balance you want in your
life and
I'm in a bunch of the questions that
you've asked and a bunch of the things
that we're talking about
just the irony of the curtains coming
down
as we're talking about mortality once
again yeah same as last time this is
just just that the Universe Works in we
are definitely living in a simulation
but but go ahead um Community tradition
and the values the faith well I mean
religion is still a lot of the topics
that we've talked about today are around
how do you
how do you balance
you know whether it's running a company
or or different responsibilities with
this
how do you how do you kind of balance
that and I I always also just think that
it's very grounding to just
believe that there's something that is
much bigger than you that is guiding
things
at uh amongst other things gives gives
you a bit of humility
um
as you pursue that Spirit of creating
that you you spoke to creating Beauty in
the world and as Dostoevsky said Beauty
will save the world
uh Mark I'm a huge fan of yours
um honored to be able to call you a
friend and I am looking forward to uh
um both kicking your ass and you kicking
my ass on the mat tomorrow in Jiu Jitsu
uh this this incredible Sport and art
that we both uh
we'll both participate in thank you so
much for talking today thank you for
everything you're doing and so many
exciting Realms of technology and human
life I can't wait to talk to you again
in the metaverse thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Mark Zuckerberg to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you some words from Isaac
Asimov
it is change continuing change
inevitable change that is the dominant
factor in society today
no sensible decision can be made any
longer without taking into account not
only the world as it is
but the world as it will be
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time